oh good morning everybody and welcome to
the developer control meeting V I hope
everybody had a good holiday break and I
hope the new year is fruitful for all of
us don't want to wish you a Happy New
Year it might not be so welcome to the
meeting my name is Cathy Guthrie I'm the
chairman today now first of all remind
you of some domestic arrangements
toilets are situated outside the meeting
room opposite the stairs cold water is
also available in the breakout area
outside the meeting room if the fire
alarm should sound please leave the
meeting room by following the fire exit
signs and meet on the Ipswich Town
Football Club training pitch do not
re-enter the building until you're told
it is safe to do so please switch off
all mobile phones or turn them to silent
I would like to remind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast live
to the Internet and will be capable of
repeated viewing the whole of the
meeting will be filmed except where
there are confidential exempt or exempt
items if you make a representation to
the meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
filmed and to the possible use of those
images and sound recordings for
webcasting and/or training purposes and
welcome to you councillor Norris we're
still just in the introduction stage so
do come and join us and everything will
be fine for continuing the council
members of the public and press may
record film photograph or broadcast this
meeting when the public and press are
not lawfully excluded finally can
members and officers please ensure that
you press the microphone speaking and
turn it off when you finish so the
introductions that I always forget first
of all we got in to pray our legal
officer good morning
we've got John Payton G senior planning
manager
it's myself of course then we've got
Robert Carmichael our governance officer
and then we've got David Daniel Cameron
why was I going to who knew David
Cameron has a bit versus licking a
crowbar I do apologize that's why I
stopped do apologize and then we've got
Mandy who's steering everything there we
also have other members of the planning
committee who will present the cases and
we've had to move around a bit because
as you can see unfortunately one of our
overhead screens isn't working so we
have all the board members who will be
able to speak on behalf of their public
but they don't vote and then we have
some more members of the District
Council out there but most importantly
are our members here elected members who
will debate and make a decision your
good selves in the chamber behind are
made up of general public applicants
agents parish councillors and those of
you who've been invited to speak we'll
have your three minutes with our
electronic timer that's usually quite
secure so without further ado may we
please move on into the agenda apologies
for absence and substitutions take a
chair we have one apology from
councillor Carter thank you and no
substitutions to receive any
declarations of pecuniary or
non-pecuniary interest by members
declarations of lobbying well I have
been lobbied on the last one the strap
rope and laps filled movements pong is
that the one you Ruth that's all is that
all members that have been lobbied on
that yep thank you very much
declarations of personal site visits
confirmation of the minutes of the
meeting held on the 27th of November
2019 these are quite short service page
one three and four and if you're happy
for me to sign that may I sign that
during the meeting thank you very much
indeed to receive notification of
petitions in accordance with the
counselors petition scheme none received
yet thank you now the planning
applications I have had a request and so
we'll be doing them in reverse order so
we'll be doing 7c will be number one
which is the Newton's form traffic road
number two will be the land off Church
Road old Newton and number three will be
the land to the west the former bacon
Factory thank you very much indeed
so further adieu Daniel if you'd like to
tell us about the benders case thank you
Thank You Jo everything is I set out in
the report free mum there's the only
thing I know in in reviewing the report
within the representation so Section B
within the summary of consultations I
know that there are seven general
comments those should of course be seven
support comments as indicated below in
that section of the report members
thinking right if we go on to the
presentation is it sir one tokens third
okay thank you
here's the location sign I'll go ahead
so we can start to get a better idea of
where we are in terms of does that move
there yes it does in terms of
constraints or identified constraints
for our mapping members we've got a
public right-of-way here coming up here
to join up with strawberryk Road and
then another one just to the bottom of
the screen there kind of to join with
travel at work or we have nothing on the
site itself if we take a wider view of
the area you can see how strongly rural
and strongly agricultural surrounding
area is if we zoom in of it here we can
see we have again defined agricultural
field patterns we have the site here
formed of an existing agricultural
building we then have a little run of
linear ribbon development along here on
here fronting on two-stroke Road we have
further development up here as well
following this road north about 1.2
miles you get to will be and then about
1.6 further up that road you get to
Stradbroke in terms of the application
before us is quite a planning history so
I just wanted to quickly run through
that we've had a few applications prior
to 2015 for conversion of the site to
provide for self catering holiday let's
was refused and we also had a change of
use from agricultural building to
dwelling-house refused we then move over
2015 we have an application for the
repositioning of an existing radicular
access which I'll come to in the photos
we have a prior approval and the class
queue to change the use of the
agricultural building to form two
dwelling houses that was approved and we
have a further full planning application
to convert upon to provide one dwelling
house the key date in there fee members
is 2015 that was when the government
introduced the revised permitted
development regime so before that day we
had
class MBA which is similar to class Q
but did make allowance for
sustainability criteria to be considered
within the application then following
that in 2016 the class Q application was
approved because we were no longer able
to give consideration to the
sustainability of the location I
mentioned that in the report is one of
40 members when we discussed the
fallback position there coming forward
we have the site location plan and we
have before is a full application for
the demolition of the existing barn and
the erection of five residential
dwellings on the site we have 2 2 bed 2
3 bed and one for bed dwelling all
served by an access here onto falls
green roads and all arranged along the
Northland access road turning head at
the end and then the end unit served off
that turning head so we have development
within this site but unable to spread
beyond if we quickly run through the
house types for you
finally we can come back to those ago
many specific questions members but I'll
just run through the site photographs
here this is the access to the site the
access being approved under that 2016
application here there is a query with
our enforcement team at the moment as to
whether that was implemented prior to
that application becoming lapsed or when
the commencement was made before I have
information from the applicant to say
that was made before and I'm gonna
invite them after the meeting to supply
that to colleagues in enforcement so we
can deal with that you can see the bond
in the background there and then this is
the northern edge of the site extending
along this row of hedgerow this is a
view from the access back down Falls
Green Road it's a single track quite
narrow without passing places and it's
unlit the b11 1/8 is at the end of that
track this is then from the same point
of the access looking up Falls green
road eventually this connects up to will
be Lane in the north and if we come down
to the b1 1/8 itself courtesy of Google
Maps we can come to we have full-screen
mode immediately here and we can see the
view up Lane is sort of hampered
somewhat by this curve in the road and
looking the other way we've got a fairly
straight stretch of road but again there
is a curve off here in the distance for
you members if we come looking down the
b1 1/8 towards the function of
fullscreen Road we obviously have that
an pink rendered farmhouse here on the
corner with the term being made
somewhere around this telegraph pole and
you can see from the turn it's difficult
to see that Junction there and then if
we come down the b1 1/8 and face up it
North we can see we have a fairly
straight piece of road with the junction
here
for numbers there we've consulted
extensively with the Highways Authority
on both the junction to the site from
full screen mode and the junction from
full screen Road onto the b1 1 1 8
highways our content with the detail
shown in terms of the access on to full
screen Road they are of the opinion that
it would be useful to seek improvement
to full screen Road however this lies
outside of land that the owner could
controller influence and is not
sufficient highways verge to implement
any improvements than for them they have
examined this junction at Falls Green
Road on to be 1 1 1 8 there are no
recorded injury accidents in the last 5
years and they are content although they
do note that the visibility splays from
this junction are substandard from what
they would like to see is that is that
better I'm getting a bit poor apologies
I'll try I'll try my best you owe me to
go back in yep so in terms of the
highways access we've consulted with the
highway authority on both the junction
to Falls Green Road which they are they
are content with at the moment the the
site enjoys agricultural access they
consider that the access of 5 dwellings
onto that road would be a the
intensification of that use with regards
to the junction at Falls Green Road onto
the b1 1/8 there of the opinion that yes
it is substandard
they do know that there are alternative
routes available to traffic at that
point it could turn left out with a site
and continue up full-screen road to will
be lame and while they note that the the
junction is substandard they know that
again it would be for them to seek
improvement
the fact that there been no recorded
injury accidents at that site for the
last five years supports that conclusion
from them if we come now into the site
itself we've got a view of the barns and
then a view towards the north there was
a pond in that area it didn't
particularly serve any ecology but we
can see from the submitted layout that
is proposed to re-implement that pond
and try and connect it up using the
existing hedgerows and strengthening
those as well to try and create some
wildlife corridors if we come along here
where the the bottom of the site now I
just wanted to draw your attention to
this line of trees here and I think it's
better seen in the next image as well
here these are proposed to be retained
within the site although transposed
to the edge of the site so we'd be
retaining those trees on the site but
moving them to provide greater privacy
to neighboring properties and then this
is a view beyond that edge to that post
and rail fence would to mark the end of
the site with fresh planting coming up
here if we run back to the site location
site layout plan sorry
here we can see that as well so we've
got retains planting on here with some
new planting to notice as well we've got
a reintroduction of the the pond and
then we have the transposed planting
here the mature trees performing this
bearing here within fresh planting up at
this end here in in looking at the
application members I think if we're
looking at a full planning application
for this site we probably be thinking
well we have some social benefit in in
the provision of the housing we have
some economic benefit through the
provision of construction jobs during
the development of the site but in terms
of its location in terms of its
connectivity to surrounding sites that
the connectivity is poor members to not
mince words
we're 1.2 miles from the nearest primary
school we're one point six miles from
that primary school on to Stradbroke
where you have a range of facilities so
we're talking about over two miles 2.8
miles to the nearest facilities I think
in this location it's highly likely that
given the fact we have unlit rural roads
obviously being unlit is a character
feature of a rural road but we don't
have pedestrian refuge and we have
vegetation growing close up to the sides
of the road I think it's unlikely that
people would be willing to walk from
this site than those facilities there is
an argument to say that maybe cycling
access could be made but I think he'd
probably have to be quite confident
cyclists and I think really there'd be a
predominance of car transport to and
from the site to meet the needs of the
residents that being said looking at the
the planning history and the fact that
we have had a class queue application
approved on this site it's now lapsed
but I think the the fact is is that we
have previously been asked whether a
class Q van conversion is is acceptable
on this site and we have
I proved that the full extent of class Q
could allow for up to five smaller
dwellings to be provided within that
site now in terms of this application
it's obviously an extension of the 2018
application of four units and compared
to the class Q we've got an additional
three units over and above the two
already provided we also have the class
Q dealt with some 380 square meters of
floor space and when we look at the the
five units now we're looking at some 585
square meters of floor space being
created that being said having regard to
the fallback position of the applicant
we could be in a position where we could
see the same quantum of development
provided on this site we could be
dealing with the same impacts and
therefore the question we're being asked
indirectly is whether we prefer to see
development come on-site and be
restricted to the barn itself or whether
we prefer to see something a little bit
more individual a little bit more along
the lines of what we have been shown I
think in the report members I've judged
the balance and and and determined that
probably the benefits of this scheme in
terms of its its design in terms of the
fact that we could be looking at the
same impacts from the site whether or
not we were keen to to approve this or
not and given the fact that we can
control some aspects of the development
as well here through imposition of
conditions has led me to a conclusion
that my recommendation to you is that we
approve subject to the conditions listed
in the report I'll turn the meeting over
to the members now and we'll have some
questions if they have any thank you so
thank you very much indeed before we
just go on to questions for itself just
to advise committee members that we do
have a parish council representative an
objector and the applicant and of course
the ward member so some of your
questions might be pertinent to them so
questions for the officer council
mathiesen and then cancel accord Thank
You chair yeah that there's two or three
points to pick up have we had a light
response from planning policy that's on
page 194 and also I I was struggling
with the concept that the row of mature
trees would be moved
that's paragraph 6.3 at page 201 so I
mean are we actually talking about
moving trees who are we actually talking
about grubbing them out and planting
some saplings in there in a better place
with regards to planning policy I've had
no comments from planning policy on this
application whether within the scope of
the consultation period or late with
regards to the replanting that is
offered by the applicants as being we
will transpose the plants and I think
what we've probably looked to do is
secure that within conditions such that
if the plants then died
within a period following completion
we'd be looking for like for like
replacements so even if it was a case of
they had all failed
following their that translocation
within the site we'd be looking for
specimens of a similar age height depth
to go in and replace them so it wouldn't
be a case of we'd be allowing saplings
there because I think actually when we
go through the photos that line along
the back there
you know beyond that line you're lending
to the rear gardens of the the
properties facing onto strawberryk Road
so I think we'd be keen to see something
on that corner that was sufficient to to
help mitigate those impacts how big of
the trees they think they're gonna move
is it better to go back to Rogers
yeah let's just go back to the history
[Music]
if we come back here it's it's this
planting here so they are substantial
but they're not of such maturity and
height that they're not going to be able
to hopefully cope with the process you
know you do see much larger significant
trees be be transposed within sight so
there is quite an operation I think
these are probably other other other
size that they could they could cope
with that thank you Jeff I know this
application for it says rely upon it but
I appreciate being reminded of the
purpose and provision of class q yeah of
course
class q exists within that permitted
development so effectively it speaks to
the conversion of agricultural buildings
to residential dwellings it provides for
a number of dwellings to be corrected
within a given agricultural dwelling I
think the the provisions talk about
three large if there are over 100 square
meters in terms of their floor flaw size
or five small if they're all
individually under 100 square meters in
terms of left floor space now obviously
it's only the the footprint of the barn
that's allowed to be converted under
class Q similarly we'd be looking for
the physical imitations of the barn to
be retained
we probably around for some reasonably
necessary works introduction of doors
windows potentially changing some
materials but by and large we'd be
looking at a you know a building that
was there was structurally sound and was
able to carry on functioning in its same
format after after the residential
conversion
any further questions yes cancer
medicine yeah I've found my other one
now you haven't mentioned and I wonder
about that what the relevance is in the
history that in the published papers
page 195 there's an agriculturally tide
dwelling in 2007 with the occupancy
restriction removed in this year what
where does that fit into the scheme of
things yeah
just into in terms of our path planning
history within the site we have included
things that come forward to us as
inquiries as well so on the one on the
wider site so part of this site used to
be connected to agricultural dwellings
facing out onto a brick road it's now
them separated from them senior planning
officer just saying just to disregard
that for the purpose of Rd dates please
thank you castle wall boss just it's
paragraphs relating to this up habitat
environment it it talks about the pond
that's shown on slide seven being
relocated improved I just wondered where
- it's not sure yeah so there was an
existing pond on the site that was
filled in if we go to site layout I
think apologies will run back through
there we go so that was in this position
here and then it is shown on the on the
site layout although the the projection
doesn't pick it up very well because
it's quite a light blue that shown is
being reintroduced here at the edge of
this strip of hedgerow that would
connect back down and round around the
site and then connect into it others off
the site thank you thank you so if we
can move on now we have representative
from the parish council and mr. Anthony
Bryant if you'd like to come forward
please
and you will have three minutes and when
you get there if you press the button on
and good will hear your comments please
thank you
all previous applications improve all
the development that Newton's farm have
one thing in common a roof height of
four meters and since nobody's property
was overlooked there were no objections
this cannot be said of this new
development plan this is bones as they
are entirely different from the simple
conversion of existing building the
neighboring populous to the site or a
mixture of single one and a half and
two-story dwellings with varying roof
Heights design of these new pot to
possibly three-story houses is of a
uniform bland generic style typical
found on new housing estates that link
from breath to suffer the linear roof -
8.2 meters is over twice the height of
the existing piggery this is an
appropriate to the location and would
unduly intrude upon the privacy of
nearby dwellings as well as dominate the
rural skyline the heightened pitch the
roof would make third third storey loft
conversions possible leading to even
greater loss of privacy
the original Q brownfield boundary shown
on site plan 401 o spoke fourteen and
three six one four stroke thirteen has
been increased by 30 percent by
incorporating an area of undeveloped
agricultural land one of the proposed
new houses were built in on this
greenfield site the original 385 square
footprint has been increased by 52% to
585 square meters so a manipulation the
planning process is possible that a
percent president may be set allowing
owners of any class q site however small
to demolish the existing builders and
extend the site into open countryside to
the route to accommodate five houses the
impact of such actions are far-reaching
especially in parishes like brandish
where there are former farm buildings on
small paths this could lead to
uncontrolled development of otherwise
protected rural areas there are two
Class Q developers in brandish the
second development a dairy farm as a
brick barn currently being converted
into three dwellings
if this full plank mission is granted it
may well set a president allowing the
dairy farm developer to apply for
additional houses outside but adjoining
the brownfield
site furthermore this would seem to
encourage other farmers to follow Newton
Farms example and knowledge they have a
good chance of getting full Planning
Commission to build five houses even
where the conversion of a farm building
is not economically viable as of
Newton's farm secondly Newton farms full
planning application may allow further
development to take place on this site
and under similar circumstances and
other sites making local plans
development boundaries in mid sukuk
largely redundant and irrelevant thank
you thank you for that members do you
have questions for mr. Bryant No thank
you very much if you just press the
button off please as we turn to MC thank
you very much indeed
thank you we now have an objector any
thing if you'd like to come forward
please
if you'd like to commence thank you very
much I represent the residents who
object to this application we are not
against the development of this plot for
housing previous applications to do so
under class queue conditions have gone
through completely unopposed but this
application represents unnecessary over
development not in keeping with the area
which is unsustainable and will damage
the environment and residents enjoyment
of it this application is to build five
very large houses not only in the
footprint of the pig shed site but also
on a green field despite being an
agricultural site the plan is to throw
Class Q conditions out of the window
with no justification yet viability has
been proven by the existing planning
consent being gained by potential buyers
and a further offer the pig sheds are
low level and unobtrusive the proposed
new houses would have a floor area of
over 500 square meters and be over eight
meters tall they would dwarf existing
neighbors brookdale farm is a bungalow
with views over open countryside if
these plans go ahead there will be a
gable end over twice the height of them
five metres from the boundary there are
no mature trees blocking their view and
this house will completely overshadow
them the proposed houses are not in
keeping with any buildings or layout
within the village 7.3 States there will
be harm to the quality of the rural
landscape all existing houses will be
impacted by the light and noise
pollution from five new family homes we
will all have our privacy encroached
upon and views spoil Falls green road is
a very quiet unlit single lane with no
passing places regularly used by walkers
the Highways Agency view unacceptable
impact is inconsistent a previous
application for for cottages was denied
due to increase volume of traffic they
anticipate only four extra cars at peak
time from five new houses there will be
at least ten extra vehicles plus food
deliveries and couriers the plans show
parking for 14 extra cars yet they say
this would be no increase the report
states the visibility of the turn on to
the main road is not up to standard they
also recommend a visibility splay of
1990 meters this is wrong as both Falls
green and the b1 weight are 60 mile
now requiring over 200 meters we live in
open countryside we have no paths no bus
routes nowhere safe for school buses to
stop
we have no pub shop or school so living
here means having a car highways
themselves say this development is
unsustainable car reliance ease our odds
with the MPPs and does not pass the
environmental test and yet all this is
ignored
there will be no economic benefit to the
area just to the developer and estate
agents work carried out so far has not
been in line with consents which raises
concern over asbestos removal 12.8 says
that adverse impacts are outweighed by
the benefits we disagree and do not
believe this point has been sufficiently
proven to make it a better option than
the existing permissions 12.1 states
this plan contravenes planning policies
but is not reason to refuse the
application why not if we don't find the
current policy yes that restricts
building developments on countryside
then the county is in trouble we will
request a peel this if it goes through
because we think protecting the beauty
of mid Suffolk is important we hope you
do too and invite you to come and have a
look thank you very much if you'd like
to just stay there the members might
have a question for you yes councillor
Matheson yeah could the officer put up a
picture or something which would
illustrate the height of the existing
shed oh I must say as I read the papers
I had in my mind's eye a large high you
know a hard barn and not a pig shed I
think that the point is very striking
from the objector regarding the height
so that's really a comment ratha thinner
than we've put that up for you but we're
on to questions at the moment so any
questions further for the lady if you'd
like to return to your seat thank you
very much indeed
we now have Rupert direct please if
you'd like to come forward
I'm not sure are you the agent is it do
that thank you
good morning counselors thank you very
much for this opportunity first of all
please may I confirm that the work on
the site's new access will start from
the 26th of March 2019 and therefore is
not in breach of any planning permission
as is stated by some of the objectives
so far today you have heard from the
senior planning officer mr. Cameron who
we have worked with closely for the last
11 months to develop this application as
he is stated that this design will be a
significant improvement on the existing
planning approval it maximizes the use
of the site completes the settlement
area and will have beneficial impact on
the local community and that the
planning department supports this
application you will hear I believe from
Council of Flatman and the other
representatives who presented the views
of the parish council that they believe
there are issues with design density
traffic and local community needs we
have addressed each of these issues to
the satisfaction of the Planning
Department and hopefully you will have
been able to had a chance to read the
short letter from Holland which outlines
our disappointment and not being given
an opportunity to engage with the parish
council highlights the fact that we have
proactively made numerous amendments to
negate issues with neighbors as well as
clarifying our belief in the
sustainability of this site I would also
like to point out at this time the
rather than build three larger houses
more profitable we have chosen five
smaller of mixed size lower cost hopes
that actually reflect the needs of the
local community targeting young families
and retired couples to bring into this
shrinking community it is these buyers
who are more likely to engage in the
community and put their children in the
local school
we've also tried to design these houses
as environmentally responsible as
possible by minimizing the use of
concrete using larger cavity walls with
more insulation opting for eco-friendly
windows and doors installing electric
car charging points solar panels air
source heating a single large treatment
plant and depending on costs I hope to
improve what we are now promising or
what we're promising now finally the
main reason I'm so driven to get this
development approved is that my family
and I currently live in a lovely house
on the outskirts of brandish but it is
rented if you approve this design it
will allow me to build one of these
houses for my family to have as our own
home thank you for your time today thank
you
have any questions I have a question
I've written down here which may be
relevant to the opposite of yourself you
want one of these houses for yourself
you've just stated yeah has there been a
housing needs survey done locally not
that I'm aware of and can the officer
advised whether we've heard anything on
there we'll come to the ward member when
we get to it so the needs of the local
community and you say it will have a
positive impact on the community could
you just sort of amplify on that please
believe so at the moment branagh she's
well brother she's shrinking it's gotten
the consensus dropped it's sort of
population by about 15 20 percent I
believe in the last sort of 15 20 years
from the consensus we did research on
there'll be an impact for the 1.4
million development costs going into the
community it will bring in younger
families and hopefully retired that's
where we're targeting with these houses
developing this houses specifically for
that those markets to bring into the
community the schools are all bar one
way below capacity and we also believe
the section 106 will add value
the usual sort of development and
requirements and one other thing a cue
scheme would were you involved in the
previous cube development no no I've
come to this haven't seen the site
looked at it I mean I've been searching
through a device thank you thank you for
your time so we now come to the ward
member thank you very much indeed and
you can either stay where you are
counseling Thank You chair members um
you've heard quite a lot of information
there I'm not going to repeat everything
I'll just give you a summer brandish PC
and residents welcome development in
fact every previous application on this
site has been supported as a single
story dwelling a similar development was
also supported and granted at dairy farm
with three bungalows we also supported
the holiday less on the Newton's farm
site because they would have been in
keeping as well at that same height so
it's not the development that's the
issue it's the density of the
development and the style the build
design does not sit well in the rural
setting this is a farm yard so it's so
it's not that that's the problem
the original footprint has been extended
by 52 percent this would not have been
approved under permit permitted
development rules also the height of the
build at present is single-story the new
application is certainly not as you have
heard from others there has been no
consultation with the parish in the
village which would unsure brought a
site forward everyone could have
supported as the development were
mentioned about start own families and
retirement I mean you're looking at
starter homes being to 2 to 3 beds and
perhaps and bungalows in their planning
officer states that the lack of stimulus
similar sites means that approval of the
proposal would not set the president
this is incorrect approval would
justified
nation of agriculture building which may
potentially satisfied permit development
requirements and replacement with five
new houses with far greater spread
height and impact than the existing
building there are very very many
farmyards in our lovely district if
members are in any doubt over this site
I would request a site visit Thank You
chair thank you that do members have a
question of the world member no I just
have one question it was mentioned I
mean we've all seen the pictures of the
lane and the B triple 1:8 I know it did
somebody say there's no buses there
anyway
none at all no buses thank you and no
can I just come back on the schools the
schools we have a syndicate of schools
strapper at blacks field will be and
many many other people from other
villages use those schools and we are at
yeah thank you
right
chair could I could I just add something
there sorry
there was actually a request to buy the
farm buildings under the queue
permission and it was turned down to
renovate them as one it's not if members
can disregard that I'm afraid that's not
a planning relevance in this debate
thank you right so we're off to our own
debate if you would please who's going
to start us off on this one a sloth
if I can rely on you I'm sure thank you
oh we need to be careful they're not
hoodwinked by the fallback position of
the classic you know classic you is
irrelevant to this application this
application is for the building full
application for five new buildings in
the countryside the classic you fall
back if this fails they could go back to
it is for one or two residents that's
actually been accepted on on a planning
previous planning permission so please
stay for the classic you fall back at
the moment I will come back to it
shortly so with that in mind this
application again is not classic you
cease the demolition of a current
agricultural building on the classic ooh
they would have built within the frame
of the agriculture building or within
the square footage of it as it's already
been explained quite well actually by
the public speakers that the actual
building size was 380 meters
this application is 585 square meters
which is significantly larger hugely
larger outside the frame of the current
agriculture building and again takes up
that whole area so it's quite
substantial build in the countryside and
I'll take you to the countryside now if
we go to page 198 and we look at 3.13
gave me the NPP F now it talks about the
three the three assessed areas one of
them is the environmental dimension
criticism of this appliques Bob the
application notes like a facility
is to support proposed dwellings sub
salutely clear that being said is well
established industry practice that sill
contributions used to ensure existing
infrastructure capacity is enhanced to
accommodate additional demand however
weight should be given to lack of
facilities when the immediate area and
with the difficulty future residents of
the sites would like to have assessing
them using sustainable transport options
which stinks right away sustainability
of the site for five properties in the
countryside we can go further than that
it talks then about the attention to the
classic you sort of come back to it on
3.17 the former application which is
their fallback was creation of two
dwellings within the current
agricultural building on the site or on
the one that's passed one dwelling
within the frame of the existing
character culture building and as we
said this is massive compared with the
former application and approval a
completely different to the classic you
so again we should really sort of ignore
the classic use on a bit in this
application and the key bit really for
me is my pen ran out so I'm going to
shoot from the hip a little bit on this
whilst I actually like the design and I
know people get off and they sighs it's
just a modern design for cific blah blah
blah they are quite nice houses and if I
had the money I'd buy something like
that in the countryside just five hours
is really really nice but I'm not in
that position and that's not what my job
here today my job today is to look at it
factually and to look at the evidence in
front of me and at the end of the day
this is five large buildings built in
the countryside in an unsustainable
location which is outside of thing that
cs1 is it of our post poor strategies so
therefore it fails on that and it talks
about that actually within this planning
document the reasons why we should
actually refuse this
yeah it's unsustainable and it's huge
I'm not going to make decision yeah but
I'm I need to refuse mainly on
sustainability over to anyone else and
John just wanted to make a comment on
something but
we're entitled to our debate I know I
done not disagreeing with a turtle
chairman just a urgent little caution in
the wording I would perhaps I suggest
that saying that class Q which is
legislation under the general permitted
development order is relevant as opposed
to not relevant but what wait you may
apply to it use your discretion of
judgment I don't want to say any more
than that thank you if I could come back
I've seen the classic you in this
application is not relevant because it's
not a classic your application but I do
get your point therefore back is classic
cube which is relevant and planning
permission has been granted into that
but for one or two properties when the
existing framework or size foot
footprint that the agricultural building
this isn't for that Casa Matheson
yes thank you I'm also you wanted to
look at paragraph 316 environmental
dimension of sustainability and when I
read that I couldn't really actually see
that there was any environmental benefit
being offered in that paragraph and as
councilor Humphries has said that this
is this is both an increase of height
and of footprint I'd be interested to
just hear from officers what class cue
says about the the height and footprint
and you know apart from that we've we've
now heard that the the objectors don't
don't really see this is an
environmental improvement anyway the
perception is quite quite the reverse
and having you know got a bit more
clarity about the height of the building
I must say I do rather agree with them
that it is it is disproportionate in the
extreme and just related to that on on
the the existing approval under class q
is that effectively to bungalows then if
it's within the existing frame of the
building so the so what we have just for
the everybody's information so planning
allows development to happen without
planning permission or with an prior
notification so things like putting a
fence up in the back of the garden is
general limited development it doesn't
require any notification of us provided
it is set within a particular criteria
for example up to two meters if it's in
a very garden class q is one of these
criterias but it's essentially the one
that refers to conversion of a barn to a
dwelling but there is a prior approval
mechanism required for the PD to be
established
permitted development to be established
there is also of a long list of criteria
of what is allowed under that provision
now one of the provisions is that the
building should not be extended by its
conversion so on that basis if it was to
qualify as a conversion under class Q
the building should maintain its shape
in terms of not being extended it can be
partly demolished and reduced in size
but it cannot be extended inside so that
would apply to both width length and
height does that help
thank you yes I have a number of
reservations about this application to
me it appears to be in a highly
unsustainable location requiring the use
of private car new public transport new
footpaths apparently in the area
actually apparently the developer didn't
consult with the Parish Council
regarding local housing needs it's built
partly on green filled land so I am
struggling with this one and I'm earring
towards recommending a refusal thank you
Thank You councillor anyone else wish to
speak counsel I said I think I concur
with the the notion of this increase of
size the inclusion of Pandora's paddock
does extend it into open countryside it
is you know the the notion of the class
queue and the sort of use of the
brownfield site gives me a sort of
contradiction there that you know it's
it's good to see the the utilization of
a brownfield site and by its nature
because it's a burn it would be out in
the countryside and it will be an
unsustainable location so that is my my
one reservation that it would be good to
see the future use of the brownfield
site which is echoed I think by the
letters of support which are very keen
to see this redundant pig farm I think
it is being demolished
rather than being converted and the
general aesthetic area being proposed
whether these five large buildings so
the appropriate means of doing that is
questionable thank you for that I think
John just wanted to
pick you up on a brand for the site
because I don't think it quite is can I
ask just the case officer think might
just put the layout plan back on the
screen in a moment and if you have just
because you've got a general layout plan
it's of an existing one actually sorry
with the abortion I thank you I'm in
respect of the land outlined in red is
all of that every cultural in use or is
it park garden at any point because the
bit to the top the North appears to be
at least on the aerial photograph I've
got one spot Assam needs to be part of a
garden it domestic garden or is it
definitely all agricultural and the
reason I'm asking this question is
simply this and if it's purely
applicable land then it is not regarded
as previously developed land if however
in this case because of the vorel
location that any part of that land was
used as domestic garden even though
everybody would assume a domestic garden
is green land domestic Gardens regarded
as previously developed land bit of an
interesting irony so there might be a
split here possibly not but one way or
the other we haven't got that proven I
guess so okay so the assumption is that
it is not previously developed land but
it can't be 100% sure maybe for the
entirety of it defined I just don't want
members to make any assumptions of
whether this is previously developed or
not in full or part if we don't have the
evidence before us to make that judgment
in it with absolute certainty does that
make sense
ultimately I would urge members to
consider just an additional point you
know we do have planning history that
has established some degree of
residential development on this site and
I would you know what wait you give that
here's obviously your discretion
I wouldn't call it I wouldn't disregard
it entirely I don't think that would be
appropriate to do that but whether you
feel this enlargement is acceptable
perhaps on sustainability basis given
the provisions of class Q are quite
tight and Pacific this exceeds that that
might be the direction you are looking
for
councillor Matheson thank you yeah well
I think probably
that doesn't seem to be a member that's
that speaking in favor of approval so I
think I will propose refusal are on the
basis of it's not sustainable on the
environmental dimension quite
specifically are you talking about
general sustainability or sustainability
to flat the size what what exactly do
okay so we've got two aspects here there
is that there was conversations about
the harm of this development in terms of
the physicality of the design and
whether it's appropriate in that in that
context and there was the other aspect
that has been discussed so far which is
really is this location suitable for
development you know in the sense of its
sustainability its connection to
services and those aspects unless you
are specifically talking about loss of
hedgerow and other aspects that's a
different issue
I would say in respect of any loss of
hedgerow and so on I'm not aware that
any of these trees or hedges are
protected and looking at the type that
they were I doubt they would be regarded
as ancient hedgerow or anything like
that
so I would be cautious to try and base
any refusal on loss of landscaping if
that was the environmental side no okay
so we're back to just general
sustainability of connections to the
site then perhaps and yeah yeah if
perhaps just just to clarify I mean I
think you know I'm sorry 316 just does
not offer a positive environmental
dimension to sustainability elaborating
that in theory at least there's no net
loss of hedgerow quite so but the
location argues against it and the
visual intrusion you know the visual
environment is is not improved as he
should be improved so that's that's the
part of environmental that I'm talking
about which presumably those fit within
that that heading generally of
sustainability
[Music]
there was Castle Humphries and then
cancelling councillor Richardson but if
councillor Richards and wants to go
first
Thank You chair and councillor Humphries
and I am also objecting to this
application but I think I just wanted
from my perspective clarify that in my
view I can accept the principle of
development on this site I think that
there is scope for that and I know that
there are there at that as principle is
supported by the local community but
from my perspective I think it's the
scale and the density that I have most
issue with I don't think this is
appropriate for the rural setting either
side so I would have much preferred to
see develop along the lines of the
classic you application previously so I
would object on on those grounds but I
can accept the sustainability of the
site in principle for a smaller and more
appropriate style of development
thank you don't castle Humphries no sure
thank you and yeah I I think since
sustainable and it's there's enough
information here under three one six I
just need to cover that and also our
core strategies as well I believe
if this klasky it's already been
approved then it will get approval
because it's a good use of an old
agriculture building it's not classic
you this is five houses in the
countryside in an unsustainable location
and because the sustainable
sustainability issues mainly I will
support the recommendation refusal and
therefore suck in that approval that's a
refusal
Thank You Cass the goal did you want to
say anything I'm sorry I've actually
risk of repetition really that I note
that community view that they would like
to see or are unsupported development of
this site despite the chalices
challenges it hurts in terms of
connectivity and and so on but for me
the it is inappropriate in terms of its
scale and size so I would object on that
basis - thank you I'm going to ant into
this I mean I've looked at all the
information that has been sent to us
obviously we
get these and it might not be something
to add to you but I mean clearly
according to all the photographs and the
reports and everything there are no foot
ways and so on highways were relatively
we can't use this in our refusal but
highways were relatively unhappy with
some of the issues but I do have before
me an appeal inspectors report on a
nearby application and it says in part
of will be Road there is no foot way
street lighting or cycled way in the
road at this point has a national speed
limit of 60 miles per hour now I believe
the Falls Road comes out onto that where
there is a 60 mile an hour speed limit
and the inspector goes on in many ways
saying that it's unsustainable and there
was a refusal on a recent application
there by the inspector so I think you
know it's interesting to note that
inspectors also find that area
unsustainable but I don't think it's
relevant to put that in a refusal or
could it be if members who've proposed
and seconded would they like that as a
little addition to it but worded a
little bit better then I'm struggling
with can we have a suggestion from our
Senior Planner on that one police
officers are mindful that this is a
finely balanced application so you know
I'm not gonna lie we did consider that
there are weight reasons for refusal as
much as approval that would come forward
so we have thought about some of these
issues that have been discussed so I'm
not gonna deny that there wasn't I have
got a refusal in front of me that I've
been tinkering with while the debates
been going forward but to sort of see if
it addresses where members are perhaps
going my version of this though does not
exclude or set aside the consideration
of part
class q and the reason for that is that
I think it would be not appropriate for
us to disregard it or set it aside we
need to if we were to refuse this
application deal with that because
that's to make a robust defense appeal
this is what the argument would center
around in part so bear with me and
you'll see where I'm going
if I read this but maybe this is a
Buckley where members are going the site
benefits from a potential fallback
position created by the previous and now
elapsed Cass cube on conversion
reference number three four eight one of
sixteen and for planning permission for
the creation of one dwelling eighteen
strike zero two zero zero eight on site
however it is considered that
application far exceeds both the scale
of development and footprint of
development established under these
positions the increase in the number of
dwellings an increase in developed area
of the site is such that is not
considered to be directly comparable and
beyond the permitted allowance of class
Q that accepts the burden of development
within strict criteria based on the
principles of reuse of existing
buildings and to restrict harm therefore
it is necessary to consider that the
development of the site would represent
sustainable development without any
potential fall back or when this
position is exceeded when weighed
against the three strands of
sustainability set out within the MPP F
while some positive benefits can be
found when considering the social and
economic impacts of development the
location of the site is poorly connected
to services and I have put including
education provision there are no nearby
facilities to speak of of such that
would be an overwhelming and as such
there would be an overwhelming
dependency on the use of private car
travel by future residents of the site
whether we then add any consideration to
of the design of the buildings and if
they were in keeping with the world
environment we could and then I would
say that consequently the scale of the
environmental harm identified and the
scale of the development when balanced
against the benefits of the side
it would be clearly an two-dimensionally
outweigh the benefits of improving the
application judged on its merits and
therefore it's contrary to all policies
h7h be one of the local plan cs1 cs2 and
cs5 of the core strategy and the NPP f
yeah well I think if if John is advising
that we need to demonstrate in the
reasons that we've considered the class
Q position then we have considered it so
you know if we need to say so then they
might absolutely accept what chance
proposed right to make a decision on
that did you want to add anything else I
think something else so what I've just
read out essentially my any question for
members is if they were to include any
Pacific considerations of the design of
the proposed development and whether it
is in keeping or outer keeping with the
surrounding existing development whether
that's in or out well I mean I the fish
that the official lack of improve was
was certainly you know quite a key part
of what I was saying so if that's needs
to be expressed as design rather than an
environmental improvement or
deterioration then again and I take take
Johnson slow Humphries I'm sorry did
does that come in to h7 in terms of the
design I was going to suggest that we
consider a phrase such as it is further
considered the design of the Perth
development would be out of keeping and
outer character with the surrounding
development and rural environment but
both the proposal and second are happy
with that - right so on that basis all
those in favor of a refusal on the point
just may please raise your hands
and we are unanimous with that thank you
very much indeed do we need to take a
break there or can we move on does
anybody need a break no can we move on
just a very quick break then if you
would please
you
right thank you very much we may resume
and we have Katherine to present my next
case which is oli Stowe upland and
whether dinner education isn't that yep
109 thank you very much thank you
and so this application is for outline
planning permission with summer
Mattia and then further to the east is
the other part of our Newton it is all
see situated adjacent to it are already
residential dwellings along the edges
this just shows that whilst at the
moment is in the outside the settlement
down boundary within the emerging joint
local plan which does have limited
weight at the moment parts of the site
would actually fall within it so this
area would fall within the proposed
settlement boundary area as would this
area it would just leave a smaller area
down here that would still fall outside
of the settlement boundary but again
it's adjacent to it and it should be
noted that I'll see as this is a draft
joint local plan it does hold limited
way at the moment
this is just an aerial map in context so
as you can see some agricultural field
at the moment and they're further
agricultural fields to the south and you
can see the residential form so that's a
site location plan and it should be
noted that there is history on part of a
site so this grade area here there was
in 2017 an application was made for the
erection of 23 dwellings it went to
committee and the members were minded to
approve and at moment it's understood
this waiting section one I see
so potentially and regardless of the
outcome of this this could still go
ahead in its current form well that's
obviously only part of foresight as you
can see so this just shows in context to
some of the services oh sorry
so it's just the site is down here you
have a community center just roughly
here the finished shot I believe is up
here there's a couple of bus stops here
which will be on a later slide and in
the primary school is slightly further
away to the east but down here that
shows as part of a proposal the access
to the site which is is down here a
footpath will be installed of C coming
out of a site as well as opposite side
of the road to link the site up to the
community center which is slightly
further away so this just shows the
connectivity so the of the entrance to a
site will be here there's going to be
footpaths along here to some I'll see
the field and be green space there's a
footpath link that will go down along
here with access to the bus stops and
we'll see the same here access to these
two bus stops so it's a short walk
approximately three hundred fifty five
or 125 meters depending on which foot
path you take out of the site
I'll see as this is outlined but the
landscaping is to be considered this is
the landscaping scheme proposed so here
you can see along the southern boundary
is quite a part of wide green sort of
green bout which will have various
planting I believe wooded area it will
allow access to the existing footpath
which will run through the site there
are connectivity points alongside Green
Acres a further footpath and
activity point along here and it or see
provide screening TV development as you
approach from myself and finishes off
the agricultural fields with the
dwelling development and this just shows
review so from a public footpath as you
were approaching the site you read first
off the encounter the the green buffer
belt there is a listed building which
also you identified here in in yellow
and at the moment this is that the
extent of C of its setting and then
further out potentially into the site as
you can see has been development to the
east there's been development of C to
the west and across the road there's
more development the proposed
landscaping scheme retains an element of
green area and open space rather than
proposing any dwellings in this to
maintain the existing setting it will
mean that the listed building still has
views out and also there are still
vendor view points from the actual
application site my footpaths into the
listed building for appreciation of its
setting in terms of aussi lay in the
scheme again outline only so if he
proposed layout of the dwellings as you
can see there is indicative but it is
suggested that should members be minded
to approve that condition is made for
bungalows in tension you've missed
location and/or see miss location in
order to protect future residential
amenity for these occupiers and also
very existing dwellings over here so
this is a site access layout it's
unfortunately the plan can't get much
bigger so it's not pretty easiest to see
and but originally highways did have
some concerns with the access and
amended if you
planless altered and also we had a speed
surveying transport so they done their
highways objections been removed men are
happy with the proposal this is just a
photograph to show the front of the site
and the access would be just behind this
miss slightly further down and then this
is from the corner at near Green Acres
which is to the west so you can see your
houses here bitters for roofline of the
list of buildings so a lot of a site
would be there with the green buffer
zone roughly coming along here so the
recommendation is for approval subject
to section 106 and other conditions it
is noted that at the moment ecology
place services have got a holding
objection due to you they been requiring
great crested newt surveys but it's
considered that we can secure this by
way of a condition obviously on
potentially any approval so that they
undertake the surveys while the section
106 negotiations are taking place and
about submission of the furthest surveys
would be needed before they make the
reserved matters
[Music]
thank you yes please do
just to add to the presentation if I
just turn attention to page 109
apologies for blank Planning Commission
HSA granted to grant outline Planning
Commission with conditions and 106 so
the header is incorrect on your papers
and I apologize for that and just as an
additional element on the or conclusion
and the conditions being recommended on
page one to nine the one to be fourth
bullet point up in the conditions which
says renewable energy scheme to be
agreed just to confirm that that is as
the wording of the Consul T response on
page 165 the last I think it's four
paragraphs and so it's referring to that
condition recommended by our consul T
and not a generic energy strategy
condition it's more Pacific Pacific than
that and it's referring to the Consul to
your small class on page 165 and
apologies if that's not sufficiently
clear thank you thank you very much two
members have questions for the planning
officer Council Richards at Richardson
please Thank You chair I just wanted to
go back to the slide where they've
circled the bungalows that would be
required by way of conditions
yes that's the one I just had a couple
of questions based on this firstly for
the ones highlights didn't pink it says
those are to be if I've understood the
color code incorrectly there to be
affordable rented flats can I just
clarify what size when in terms of
number of stories they they would be and
secondly what they are adjacent to in
terms of the properties around them that
makes sense
okay so it's for outline we've only
access the landscaping to be considered
so in terms of one the location of the
affordable housing and also the style
height that's not up for consideration
so whilst it's slightly it's indicative
so it doesn't mean that that's what will
be approved so that's not up for
consideration in terms of what sort of
is it them I believe it's sort of car
parking areas and garages but I may may
be incorrect on that point I think yeah
I was gonna say I think there's these
are properties I mean I think there's a
area of parking here and here
but yes so in terms of their height and
everything else it it will come in at
the reserve matters and I'll see how
that point we come and assess the
implications and residential mmunity for
that medicine yeah again except it's
thanks that oh she's gone
same slide please oh well done yeah
accepting that that this is not the
reserved matters but I just want to flag
up also on that layout that as far as I
can see and it's a bit small etcetera
but we've got all the older twenty-two
affordable czar in a single a single
block effectively a single part of the
site and that's contrary to what the
officers have requested housing enabling
officers have requested right and we do
it later if it should be approved today
yeah Thank You Joyce
yeah anyone else have any questions for
the officer
no yes castleball voice thank you could
you mentioned as an existing planning
application for this
yes so we'll see the whole site is
within redline including that that this
area had a planning application in 2017
was made for 23 dwellings like I said it
went to committee and members approved
it a committee in a moment it's still
sacked within the planning system and my
understanding as of last week and even
this week is that these sections 106 is
still yet to get underway I've spoken to
the agent or see if this application
were to be approved they would withdraw
potentially withdraw that application
they could only carry out one scheme
anyway but that area was previously
recommended for approval and granted it
committee thank you thank you for that
thank you very much no more questions in
that case then we can move on to the
parish council and Jonathan Miller if
you'd come forward please
that's it
hi thank you the proposed development
was discussed at parish council meetings
as part of the pre-application
consultation the outcome of these
meetings was that there was no support
either from the Parish Council or public
it was felt the proposal will have a
negative impact on old Newton's
landscape and appearance especially
because the elevated position in the
village it would also impose a further
strain on the infrastructure provision
which is already stretched one point
there the school is full and children
are having to be bussed out of the
village to other villages for their
education in the emerging joint Local
Plan old Newton is designated interim
village and the district council has
already stated each of these villages
should have to provide about 30 new
properties in the period between 2018
and 2036 ole Newton has already met its
development requirement as nearly 60
dwellings have recently been passed with
either full or outlined planning so
therefore we have doubled the
recommended numbers also with regard to
the proposed development a significant
area of the site is outside the
settlement barren boundary as detailed
in the draft joint local plan so it
represents an ad hoc developments
without the safeguards of strategic
planning the planning officer however
did comment on the parish councils
feedback on the proposed development and
stated within the adopted core strategy
document 2008 old Newton is classed as a
primary village it is noted within the
emerging draft of joint local plan it is
classed as a hinterland village however
this is only in regulation out 18 and
therefore holds very little weight it is
disappointing that the planning that
planning appears to be of hearing to a
outdated 2008 policy and not taking a
proactive approach in aligning more
closely with e more emerge
joint local plan but if is if this is
the case it should be noted the whole of
the proposed development site is outside
the settlement boundary of the village
and therefore as mid Suffolk care of
their five-year land supply it should be
refused the proposed development will
also in crow on the setting of several
heritage acetate assets curb which a
list of buildings I know the planning
office only mentioned one the harm
identified is considered to outweigh the
benefits of the development as
determined in the national planning
policy framework as consistency in
decision-making is important it should
be noted that the council's heritage
department has recently refused a much
smaller developments just down the road
partly on the basis that the proposal
affects the character setting and
significance of gray to listed heritage
assets of a similar farmhouse and
cottages country to the NPP F you're now
on your three minutes could you finish
okay there are other sites that are
similarly being identified as the
heritage state one other area is the
concern on wildlife Italy because the
site is a meadow that has been in meadow
status for over 40 years thank you thank
you very much would you like to stay
there just switch the button off and
some of there might be some questions
for you just for a moment please
any questions for gentlemen No No thank
you we did hear everything you said
thank you very much indeed
and now we come to mr. short please the
agent for the site
oh sorry oh my gosh oh I beg your pardon
sorry mister I've crushed you I do beg
your pardon mr. heli well is it Michel
le well I beg your pardon sorry I
crushed you off and I got the wrong
pressings off please come down it's the
pills I'm so sorry
so this gentleman is an objector mr.
Halloran thank you this this application
is from the state of 64 dwellings which
on your figures will represent
approximately 160 extra residents in the
village of approximately 1,100 residents
Planning Commission already exists for
over 60 other dwellings in the village
so our village population is expected to
increase by nearly 25 percent in one
short hit this is a country village not
an overspill town and it is does not
represent controlled development in any
way shape or form
most of the site is outside the Greve
settlement boundary and partly on
ancient meadow that hasn't been plowed
for well over 50 years this meadow would
actually be a wonderful wildlife site
for the community why is this happening
at all why are we here who needs this
development well certainly not those
living in the village none of whom have
supported it verbally or in writing
presumably not be Suffolk Council
because they've already admitted they
have an adequate supply of housing or
proof sites for their future needs this
only leaves the land owners and
developers it seems a whole proposal
goes back to an outdated development
plan for 2008 and not on the news
properly thought out strategic plan
which is its final stages where we are
now classed as a hinterland village and
therefore should be subjected to much
lower development well perhaps it's
because the infrastructure already
exists nonsense
Church Road is already very busy and
enough and not wide enough to want even
a central white line it's poorly lit
with little pavement and is often single
lane due to parked cars on each side it
is very dangerous and I live on it for
mums and dads walking their parent their
children down to the village school and
back as well as the dog walkers the
school itself as we know is already
oversubscribed and children in the
village are already being transported to
other schools at your expense well
perhaps it brings some benefits to the
village what there's minimal local
employment with no more currently
planned so commuting to work and to
shopping and by the way still market is
three miles away
not 1.8 it will only increase the
traffic on the busy bee travel 1/3 and
it equally congested a 14 is this part
of your plan the bus service you
mentioned three to four buses a day it's
a bit of a joke and it's hardly used
we have no pub now and where is the
restaurant you mentioned even the walked
from the new residents to the village
shop you will have to cross the road
five times if you want to stay on the
pavement if you don't believe me try it
and what about the less and substantial
impact this will have on the great to
unlisted plant from Pond Farm Cottages
and Burnham cottages they will be
surrounded as well pom farm barn and
probably the most important
architectural a and historically the
clay lump burning please why shouldn't
they be afforded the same protection as
listed ash Burnham kosh's and the grange
were last year on basis the proposal
affects a character setting and
significance of these heritage assets
and was turned down this development is
unwanted and unnecessary and I urge you
to reject it thank you
members do you have questions can't
cancel war boys yes please thank you I'm
not sure this you'll be out answer this
with previous speaker mentioned that
this was a meadow status mutton meadow
meadow is this Chapel si or is it is it
a Site of Special Scientific Interest oh
I've gotta wear actually be registered
as such but would make a very good site
I can answer that one no it isn't it
isn't registered as a site unfortunately
Meadows are few and far between on LI
right any further questions
no then thank you very much indeed for
your passionate response thank you sorry
I missed you earlier and then was
Celeste short please if you'd like to
come forward thank you
good morning members I'm Leslie short of
Ardizzone planning and I represent the
applicant can I just draw your attention
to the nature and character of the
development proposed for this site the
site measures about nine acres and
old-money of that site area over two and
a half acres is public open space and
structural landscaping so almost 1/3 of
the site is a functional landscape area
screening the development but at the
same time enhancing wildlife habitats
and enhancing biodiversity prospects in
terms of housing development about two
acres is already the subject of a
positive resolution by this council 423
dwellings and an additional acre is
allocated for housing the council's new
draft plan the scheme before you today
embraces the council's prior commitments
but is capable of delivering much more
for the benefit of the district and the
local community turning to planning
policy where those policies which are
much most important for determining a
planning application are out of date
paragraph 11 of the framework mandates
permission should be granted unless
there are clear reasons for refusing the
proposal or adverse impacts outweigh the
benefits members your council officers
accept and advise you that certain local
plan policies are out of date within the
definition prescribed within the
framework it is therefore common ground
that the most important policies are out
of date thereby triggering the need to
apply the so called tilt advance in your
decision-making today applying that
tilted balance means the issue Grand
Planning Commission for sustainable
development except where the benefits
are significantly and demonstrable
outweighed by the adverse impacts so
what are the benefits of the development
and what are the harms growth in the
scale and visit in this application is
appropriate in principle to a primary
village this proposed development
constitutes growth but it's still
relatively small-scale
but vital growth the application site
lies adjacent the existing settlement
winery is well connected to the key
services and facilities this village has
to offer many are within walking
distance it is also well connected and
in close proximity to snow market the
scheme will deliver 64 dwellings which
will assist the council in meeting its
housing need which should carry
significant weight the scheme will
deliver 22 affordable dwellings
sister canceling meeting a continuing
affordable housing need this too should
carry significant weight in your
decision-making the scheme will deliver
a wide choice of quality market and
affordable homes many of which will be
single-story we're showing 17 bungalows
in the indicative layout and so again
delivering benefits within the social
limb have any sustainability assessment
in terms of economic benefits there will
be a short-term boost probably for about
three years to employment but a much
more substantial contribution in the
long term to the local economy from the
new residents of the housing helping to
maintain the variety and vitality and
viability of local services both in old
Newton and adjacent villages in terms of
the environment the proposed development
comes with a combined ecological and
landscape strategy which will secure
effective mitigation and biodiversity
enhancement and be a positive asset for
the community you will see that on slide
12 so what you see today before you is
deliverable when these benefits are
weighed against the low level identified
it's clear that they do not
significantly into wants to be out where
the benefits and I don't you to agree
thank you thank you
members do you have any questions for
mr. short no I just have a question
which possibly is not relevant but
relevant is this developments involved
with the same person you are one and the
same for the already approved section of
it it's the same landowner but the the
inference or rather the specific
suggestion in conversation or engagement
with the case officer is that if this
development is approved the other
application will be withdrawn using the
same developer the same no it's not no
no thank you cows are gold attendant its
permitted but I have a question that
arises from what the speakers said but
would is probably a matter well it is a
matter for the officers and it concerns
this matter about policies being out of
date and I as I understand it recent
cases have demonstrated
that there is a test of relevance that's
my term not just saying the lawyers turn
that there is a test of relevance it
means that policies aren't automatically
out of date they need to be considered
in terms of the context of the specific
application before us appreciate some
advice that is true but mid Suffolk
policies how can I put this delicately
have been pretty much tried and tested
and destroyed as appeal in the last year
in terms of being out of date so as much
as there is a test developed the test
development has pretty much been
overhauled on the appeal circuit and not
least thanks to the wolf it appeal when
it was very clearly declared that the
housing supply to policies that we have
are clearly out to date and that is with
or without developments to the five-year
land supply so I would add I would say
that if we were to try and defend that
point we have a lot of appeals that
would be against us in order to put any
kind of robust appeal around that issue
I think Thank You mr. Shaw we may return
to your seat thank you very much indeed
and why we come to Council even if you
look face thank you thank you very much
chair and good morning members this
application is not supported by the
local community and as many impacts on
the village and villagers you have seen
comments from residents on the ecology
of site on rights of way traffic issues
children walking to school and status of
old Newton in the emerging plan as a
hinterland village the bus service has
also been reduced recently making the
village less sustainable and I note in
the papers the officer of first hold
Newton as a core village again this is
in the old core strategy that were
frequently told to apply to wait - due
to its age there's already planned
permission for 23 homes
tucked in behind Green Acres
and mutton meadow within at the
settlement boundary this is almost a
third of the homes proposed in the
current application and that's been
approved at outline as you've heard this
application covers a much larger area
the majority of which is outside the
existing and proposed settlement
boundary and the officer report states
there is no overriding need to approve
sustainable development outside of
settlement boundaries and this view
should be adhered to
currently the meadow and farmland
outside of the settlement boundary
provide a buffer separating the village
from the farm houses to the south and
the east for Philip the core village is
a high point in the landscape and the
application site will be prominent in
appearance when they're viewed from the
southwest and from the Northeast which
lawson they're negatively impact on the
rural nature of the village it's also
impact the setting of pond farmhouse and
will cut off the connection between the
listed building and the surrounding
farmland
adjacent to this site is a pond by which
it's known a great crested newts breed
ground nesting birds are also found in
the meadow this application will be
extremely harmful these ecologies which
cannot be replaced a mitigation for this
has not been provided including the
outline that they approved outlines
application that's already approved
there are over 80 houses approved in old
Newton the villages own housing survey
identified a need from much smaller
number and the strategic housing team
have identified a very small number of
housing needed this contravenes many
policies CSO 2:05 816 HB o 1 and CLO 8
name but a few
there's no need to approve this
application one already exists tucked in
behind the existing housing and for all
the reasons I've given I'd urge the
committee to recommend refusal
thank you very much chair thank you did
numbers have any questions for
councillor no
thank you I have a statement from Keith
Welland who unfortunately couldn't be
here
old Newton is a hinterland village in
which according to the draft local plan
development will be permitted with ended
settlement boundaries when certain
criteria are met most of the proposed
development site is outside the proposed
settlement boundary it should be noted
as in the case of the current Gladman
application in Stowe upland that site is
within the draft JLP proposed settlement
boundary but outside the settlement
boundary are set out in the approved
neighbourhood plan in that location
officers have told me that they would
recommend the application to be approved
up to the JLP proposed settlement
boundary for consistent the old Newton
application should be refused as much of
the site is outside the proposed
settlement boundary it is also outside
the existing settlement boundary even if
the site were wholly within the proposed
settlement brown boundary there are
criteria which would need to be met
before the site should be approved this
proposal would fall at the first hurdle
the design is not sympathetic to the
rural surrounding and does not
demonstrate high-quality design the
proposed site is on the edge of the
settlement in its own developed State it
makes a contribution as a gap between
the edge of the village
and farmland it is on high land above
the Gipping Valley and can be seen from
some distance the listed building is set
close to and can be viewed from this
undeveloped land if the application is
approved then the open setting will be
lost in hinterland villages according to
the draft JLP the cumulative impacts of
proposals will be a major consideration
47 properties have already been approved
in Winningham Road and smaller
developments are
so proposed if this application is
approved the impact upon the village
infrastructure would be unacceptable
there would be additional traffic on
Church Road which is a route to school
for with for most of its length
no footpath there is an existing and
proposed Junction virtually opposite the
location of the proposed access to the
development site resulting in additional
road safety hazards and potential for
collisions and that's councillor Keith
well in a statement thank you so we are
now into debate we'd like to kick off
with that one today please councillor
Matheson thank you yeah picking up that
very last point from Council of Wellum
can we look at the the map of the
village to see that that point about the
lack of walking facility to the school
how does that actually work possibly
councillor Evo may be able to help us on
that as well
a sigh entrance will be here and this
part is a story and the school is here I
think in my report does acknowledge or
CV there's no foot path along the east
and they'd have to see walk on on the
road or see all the residents at the
moment would be doing the same anyway
school remember sight sir I think it
would be helpful if the ward member are
we happy to at our support member yes
Thank You chair yes the majority of the
route the children walk along the road
and the head teach has been very
successful in encouraging parents and
children to walk to school by um parking
if they have to drive there but in the
park in the village hall car park which
is opposite the side and then walk the
majority of the way is actually just on
the road there is no foot putt there is
no but no footpath that's the
information yet lovely right continue on
this one my chair thank you I have some
real concerns with this in a moral sense
really and then we'll come onto the
regulations the moral sorrow is this
that there's Mississippi district
councillors already written its joint
local plan well that's at regulation
eighteen we've identified this place on
Newton as a hinterland village of the
future which means limited amounts of
construction and I just like to ask the
question if it was a hinterland village
which is not at the moment
what would be the maximum amount of
buildings permitted before I carry on
and equip the debate I was kind of
hoping you were going to ask this
question because I don't think you're
gonna like the answer no actually your
problem here is let's start from the
beginning so the current local plan
defines this village as a primary
village now actually what was quite good
about the
core strategy was that it did kind of
have a hierarchy so you had towns you
had key server centers you had farming
villages and then he had secondary
villages ironically only secondary
villages had a cap on development which
was infill which was defined as one or
two houses the others primary key
service for this is primary didn't
actually have any cap on the development
that you could have within the
settlement boundaries looking now at the
policy SPO three and the hinterland
villages policy in order to be in
accordance with the NPP F it doesn't
have a cap on development at all for any
level of development type villages so if
you put a cap on the number of houses it
would be instantly contrary to the NPP F
so ironically we were into this very
interesting policy balance our current
policy which has a cap within its policy
and we've already established is out a
date because it's non-compliance with
the MPP F the future policy which
doesn't have any cap on development
anyway for Intel and that development
would be in accordance with the NPP F
but it has very little weight because of
course of its emerging status so these
are the balance that you need to to look
at this gets more complicated because
ultimately we have a change in the
settlement boundary as an emerging
change of that settlement boundary so
there are now effectively two parts of
this site that would be within the
proposed settlement boundary one of
which has already got 23 houses resolved
to be approved on but that's not the
decision as yet it's been resolved
interestingly after the other section of
land that's been included within the
settlement boundary is directly opposite
and other listed building so that
consideration of that has taken place
over there what we're dealing with in
respect to what is outside this of the
proposed settlement about three be
careful what I say is a lot of
landscaping there's a one middle section
that he's essentially the fresh bit that
would be new developments
behind the proposed settlement boundary
that said all of that has little weight
because what we should be dealing with
is the current settlement boundary but
our policy on that is out of date
unfortunately so my conclusion on all of
this is we are left with the NPP F and
whether or not is a sustainable
development judged on its merits Thank
You Leon
so yeah still I've still got real food
people on they sit on the moral side
because this is outside the settlement
boundary for the majority of this
development which seems to me is we've
got five-year land supply under Section
11 of the MPP F there's no requirement
actually to pass this so and that's what
our combatives my full stop on this one
unless I'm wrong and if we can put the
map up please of the future settlement
boundary with the site on it please
that's the one that's it
as you can see majority even though the
bottom bit I agree is landscaping there
is still a large proportion of that
which will be developed now inside of
the settlement bound in fact quite a lot
of that be developed actually it's only
a small band that's landscaped on the
bottom south side the area to the left
within the settlement boundary that's
the area I believe that's already been
given permission for planning permission
so there's no change there and if this
one goes through its that's a merits
fine and the only other bit that they
could actually build him within the
settlement area is up towards the
entrance onto the the main road which is
quite small so this development under
the future and the on the proposed
settlement boundary the majority of the
development I would argue is outside of
the settlement boundary we could go down
to square meters but just looking at
that the majority of it is outside of it
is it not we're not denying that well
actually at the moment the entire thing
is outside of the current local plant
settlement boundary and if this had or
if you give this emerging plan more
weight in your discretion of your
judgment ultimately I'm not denying that
degree you know more than
half of the development will still be
outside of the settlement boundary what
I would urge you to do though is
identified the harm in that respect and
what is demonstration or harm in respect
to the MPP F you know whether he's in or
outside that said my boundary
I hate safe is not going to be a robust
argument in respect of any appeal okay
thank you so it's outside of something a
boundary section 11 of the MPP F says
that actually because you've got a
five-year Lance blog you don't have to
actually approve this on balance though
you're right what's the harm so if I
arrived from space from a spaceship and
I hovered over all you look down and
where I need to build some houses
because we need bungalows and we need
affordable housing within mid sipper we
definitely do where would I put it
that's a definite really obvious input
place that I'd build so I understand why
they want to develop there and
understand the need for the buildings
and this is it it's a balance at the
moment although it's moral bit that goes
to me what's outside a settlement
boundary it is a small village I think
it is quite a lot of buildings for a
small area but on the other hand we do
need houses between the bungalows do
need for browsing and that's a suitable
place for it it's a bit of an issue
isn't it and the local emerging local
plan or lousine regulation 18 it doesn't
have no weight it has little weight and
we can come back to that can't we yeah
IV I I'm carefully read through these
the each each applications report and
perform a series of mental somersaults
regarding the the settlement boundaries
and the only weather policies are are
material or not material etc etc and and
and in this this particular one all the
larger part of this particular one it
does at least seem to me that that the
two settlement boundary policies both of
which have limited weight
both of which the same well actually we
don't think this is the right place for
whatever reason and so you know that is
it is still a factor in the overall
scheme of things here beyond that I
thought I think this it's tricky and
it's on balance and it's a bit hard to
argue need so I'm still sitting on the
fence thinking about this one at the
moment I think there are a few people
chuckling it's a really difficult one
does anyone else wish to speak because
we're gonna have to sort of move the
debate on counselor wall boys
my immediate reaction is is a sort of
supportive comments of the parish
council I think in old Newton you seen
the cumulative effects of of development
and rightfully bright concerns about
future development where you've got
counting the 47 new houses on finning
ham Road that 24 had already agreed on
this site that's up already 71 houses
which is far in excess of what their own
house in survey needs require they do
have some facilities within old Newton
but as has been explained the primary
school is is actually full capacity
children are actually going to have to
be bussed to further afield and the
resources of the village are already
overstretched it is good to see the
affordable housing and it be reluctant
to sort of lose the affordable housing
but I think the scale of the development
is is in excess of what will be
appropriate Froude Newton and there is
also the loss of the amenity land the
meadows and the diversity of wildlife
that already exists there
thank you does anyone else wish to speak
I mean we're going to have to sort of I
could make a decision or keep our
thoughts to ourselves it really is a
difficult one because I mean I'm on the
focus group working on the joint local
plan and it does seem to be grinding or
never slowly but we've got to accept
what we've got at the moment to deal
with our decisions
yeah councillor gone Thanks we can agree
that this is this is far from far from
clear-cut V the although the emerging
joint local plan itself has limited
materiality the reasoning thinking and
evidence that lies behind the
development of the joint local plan is
it's clearly valid you know because it's
there in the joint local planner what
wait in formal terms we can give to the
plan itself may be may be limited so the
way the settlement boundary is being
drawn in that joint local plan is
obviously for a reason based on some
some evidence and some policy rationale
it seems to me that that we already have
permission for part development of that
site which is in accord with the joint
local plan could be said to meet
certainly the known needs more than the
know needs of our to Newton as things
stand and and therefore that that seems
to me to be logically a position to go
to and saying that actually the
sixty-three is
63 prop that have been already agreed
subject to there's almost the the end of
it for me in terms of the development of
this site if settlement boundary is a
concept that has any meaning we ought to
stick with it I think because all we
know is that you know today's boundary
is always at risk of becoming tomorrow's
creep so maybe for me I think I'm I'm
settling on a position in my own mind
which is about what we've agreed is is
it really and I'm kind of minded against
the proposal though not convinced I
haven't convinced myself sufficiently to
to make that a proposal
that's better say yes thank you for that
I think that's where everybody's
struggling at the moment I think that's
a very useful comment however and there
is something on page 1 1 8 regarding the
ecology and one of the objectives
mentioned that the the field is you know
although it's not designated it's an
important area and they have said that
put a holding objection in due to
insufficient ecology information and I
wonder whether at the moment that might
be something that we could defer on at
the moment because they haven't got all
the information in and it was flagged up
that this was an important ecological
site I wonder what members think about
that
councillor Madison yeah I mean I I've
certainly got some sympathy with with
that the the other thing I wanted to
just ask about we've we have had
recently nice to say you know recent
meetings going back increasing emphasis
on deliverability and I haven't noticed
any particular comments either that
we've heard or in the report about that
so I the the
that the the the approved 24 I think it
wasn't only that the section 106 was was
under discussion it was I think it was
not under discussion I think if I got
that part
rightly from mr. patron gee I just
wonder whether officer comment on that
might help although I do sympathise with
the chairs point I think deliverability
I think would be I was going to say that
would be something that the officer
needs to discuss with the applicant
perhaps outside this room so I wonder if
that's another reason we could defer
this at the moment for further
investigations we we don't I'm checking
with the case officer as I speak but I
we don't have I'm not normally was
required but it is a it has been
recognized as a consideration and one of
the considerations is is the digit of
ability of development and you know how
fast on site will developer get to build
out the scheme and ultimately we don't
have any details around that at this
time it's obviously in this form I can't
disaster the applicant to produce that
that might either be a straightforward
no we can't give you that information or
it might be they need to go away and
work on that and come back with a
proposal so they're you know on that
basis that would be something we'd have
to go away and look at if that was an
additional information the members
needed that would give weight one way or
another to their deliberations can I
just ask legal and then if we asked for
that information and the ecology could
we go for a deferral if the committee's
don't feel they have enough information
to make a decision today that would be
entirely proper that's obviously the
majority of you the committee thank you
yes counselor I saw a hand that hit was
it your counselor Humphries yes please
how much have we not got to be careful
on that this outline Planning Commission
and it does Somalia notes that there
would be a condition put in that you'd
get that information and going on again
this is a really difficult one no matter
how you look at it it's really difficult
because blowing people's emotions we're
talking about out-of-date regulations
we're talking about the moral component
of this as well and doing what's right
and and that's that I hate those
positions because there's all these
things working against each other and
I've got a question about
overdevelopment or perceived over
development of this village rather than
its site and whether that has any weight
or value because to me this is over
development of a small rural village in
cific it's in excess of what's required
there's no requirement for this
additional 64 houses we've already have
planning permission granted for part of
it
I just wonder what the weight would
might be or how would how would come to
a conclusion that this might be over
development of the village rather than
the site I go back to my original
standing point with the selling point
which is ultimately what is the
demonstrational harm I'm sorry to put
that forward but you know the number
game is a number game you know we could
have X many houses been and I had to say
there are villages that have had
exceeding high numbers of houses being
added to their village and ultimately
we've got to get down to is does that
cause a problem which severe traffic
impact does that cause a problem with
facilities within the village that are
unable to cope with that you know it's
those individual planning considerations
that are part of that question not it's
too many houses because I can't argue
too many houses is a problem if I don't
have the reason why it's a problem to
follow Casa de Richardson
much like all the other councillors have
already spoken I am conflicted about
this application there are aspects that
I like about it aspects that I don't I
think to start with our talk on a sort
of slightly more positive note other
things which I do think are commendable
about this application I think sorry yes
I've got a slight slight cold so
apologies for that
and so I think firstly I do welcome the
fact that there are a large number of
affordable homes as part of this
application I do welcome the large
number of bungalows and the
consideration has been given to their
location within the site to avoid any
overlooking or loss of residential
amenity and I do think actually I do
commend the extensive work that's gone
into the landscaping around this
application I do think that is a very
welcomed consideration that we don't
always see in applications or
developments of this size what I am
uncomfortable with which has already
been mentioned again but I would just
reiterate my own views that it does that
the number sheer number for a village of
this size and the questions about
whether or not it's genuinely needed I
think it's a valid point and I do
understand and share the concerns about
the questions of it being outside both
the existing settlement boundary and the
settlement boundary proposed in the
joint local plan so I'm not happy with
those aspects but what the slight
concern I have is and why I don't think
I would support a deferral it's because
on from my personal perspective I don't
think there's anything about the
existing ecological studies or the
deliverability that would affect my
decision-making for this application I
think for the most part the question we
know what the issues are is just how
much weight we attach to different
aspects of our concerns so whilst I
think I do recognise those concerns it
does go down to I think a question of
the policies that we have to comply with
and although I am unhappy with aspects
about the settlement boundary about the
size of this development I don't think
there is any harm that I could be
certain I could identify and whilst I
don't like this application I am leaning
towards the view that I can't find a
valid reason for refusal that would
stand up against appeal
right so we need to move on so how we're
going to move on on that that we've
heard from everyone is everyone said
what to say
councillor Matheson where are you are
you take up the chairs hints about and
deferral you know I think the arguments
for deferral are not not brilliant but
that they are that they are there and we
I mean we've had and I mentioned
deliverability we have had I can't
remember whether it was mr. payment G or
mr. is bill sitting in that chair a
couple of meetings ago wanting to attach
considerable weight to the issue of
deliverability and I now need to achieve
five hundred and whatever it was houses
a year or else our policies would be
held below the waterline again and so I
think that is a significant point which
we should explore and I did just wanted
to clarify that the does the existing 23
deliver seven affordable to policy as
well yeah I believe it's eight so what
was your conclusion on that
ecology undeliverable counselor called
yes thank you for that job I think we
need to have we defer it we do so for
genuine reasons we don't do so because
the decision is is a difficult one and
we don't know what to do I don't think
that's fair to fair to anyone so there
are either substantive reasons for for
deferral or not I I remain very
concerned about this feels
disproportionate can infer from gluten I
but we've been challenged to find a
reason in terms of harm which I I like
cancer which is in struggling struggle
to do I fit so it seems that the reasons
for turning it down that might otherwise
be logical and rational aren't available
to us we have to find reasons in in
welcome to the world of planning yeah we
have to find reasons we that are
legitimate in planning terms but I I
don't think personally I can support
deferral unless we we have substantive
reasons for doing so right John John was
just going to give us a bit more oh if I
may suggest just in terms of reasons to
defer ecology you know as a council we
are you know under a duty to protect
habitats and and we failed that Duty we
can actually be exposed to significant
cost now we as officers have felt that
we given the amount of landscaping land
available and the opportunities even the
worst case scenario we felt we could
condition the mitigation sufficient
enough to deal with that however members
may feel that they need further
information on the ecology issue upfront
in order to assure them in terms of the
right decision in terms
come alive with that duty and so I don't
I do regard that as a very good
substantive reason to defer if that is
your members wishes on the terms of the
deliverability yes it is upheld as a
quite think can be upheld as a
significant factor to give weight to now
if you are on such a a balancing act it
might be that material consideration of
the deliverability of this scheme and
how certain and in what time frame the
deliverability of this mean become a hit
comes forward that maybe even if it's
only a small bit of weight additional
weight that would lean your opinion one
way or the other in respect to going
forward on this development as a
material consideration so how
significant weight you give that is it
as a reason to defer it it ultimately
your judgment but you may wish to do
that and you can do that I don't see any
particular legal reason why not as my
colleague here has suggested if I can
help any further please also just a
point on that it would come back to this
committee if they'll do go down that
route so you know we still have the same
considerations and if people feel they
can make a decision today then you know
then we need to make that decision but
John did youdid actually propose it
didn't you and there is no second at the
moment I threw it out from the chair I
must admit yeah but I was just trying to
help the the debate moving forward you
know so I don't know if we have a safe
we don't get a seconder then we have to
move on is that right yeah so if we
don't get a second that the motion would
fall and we'd be back to being normal
debate as very useful so and you know
although I started it I'm not going to
finish it so if there is no second Iran
on that basis then are you going to make
a decision later no gentlemen you know
you really must or we must so that will
fall yeah so then we also counts the
Richardson thank you chess I again just
before
the previous points that I made that
having reflected on it and listened to
the debate although I'm not happy with a
number of aspects of this application I
do think it would have an unpleasant
impact on the neighborhood and on local
community I don't in planning terms
think there is enough of a sufficient
reason to refuse so on that basis I will
reluctantly propose that we accept the
officers recommendation and approve this
application Thank You councillor
Richardson and so councillor please
mojo yeah likewise there's no legal
reason to refuse this there and that's
what we're down see the moral component
is there and that and the rights and
wrongs are there but that doesn't stand
up in law and I think the problem is it
would come back as it would come back to
us and and I think we'd lose because
there's nothing here to support refusal
nothing so therefore all second the
approval all right thank you that I've
just sort of had a word with John there
and we can do a lot in reserved matters
when it comes back again which is
important so I have a proposal in the
second there all those in favor
reluctantly though might be please vote
now please thank you and those against
three and thank you very much to
everybody it is not an easy decision
it really
is not thank you so if we move on now
please to the final matter land to the
west of the bacon Factory at home as
well
right then to find a case down here like
you would face that would be excellent
thank you
Thank You chair yes we've got another
outline application this time in Elms
well it's let's just get this right
erection of sixty five dwellings with
all matters reserved to safe for that of
access so there's even less detail for
you members so in terms of reserved
matters we'd be dealing with layout
appearance scale and landscaping only
access would be secured at this point
this is a site here it's roughly
triangular if you can try and give it as
much a shape as you possibly can
we've got the rest of as well here if we
look at constraints we have a great two
listed building located here and we have
a number of footpaths so I'll just try
and take you through them now members
because that'll influence that will
that'll become important when we come to
the photographs as well so there's a
public right-of-way extending along here
to the north of the railway line and
also along here the south of a railway
line that crosses the railway line at
certain point and then comes up through
this development here go through that as
well when we get there there's also
polarizer boy coming along the edge of
this development and then coming up and
joining the network the north and also
comes along the top of this field as
well now in terms of the footpath
network there are a number of stops due
to work so this footpath here that
crosses the railway line is stopped as
it comes through here and also this one
is stopped as well due to the ongoing
development of this site here and I'll
come to that in a moment as well so if
we come to the aerial map
apologies members are aerial maps that
probably aren't quite as up-to-date as
things on the ground we've still got the
formal Grampian factory here we've got
an industry existing industrial site
here formed of a number of buildings and
businesses we've then got the edge of as
well here running along the railway line
and then continue any up station road
here if we update and have a look at the
map courtesy of Google Earth we can see
some development ongoing here that's as
part of the 2013 Taylor Wimpey planning
permission that was approved on this
site here and then if we go forward
again when we come to the pictures as
well members I'll update you on on that
development it's quite well advanced we
then come here and this shows the
relationship between the Taylor Wimpey
site and the application site that we're
looking at here this is one of the
master plans for the Taylor would be
such a superimposed upon on the layout
here so if we come closer we see the two
post layout superimposed against one
another in terms of the illustrative
master plan this area to the north here
is to provide an attenuation Basin for
sustainable drainage we've then got sort
of three blocks of development here here
and then here and we've got two access
points one located here and one located
here that we'll come on to in more
detail and those would provide access
through the Taylor Wimpey site onto
Station Road here so if we come closer
into the district master plans the
Taylor Wimpey site provides a spur of
road to punching to the very south of
the application site and then further up
as well there's a turning head which
would affect become a t-junction
I also wanted to just bring forward the
contents of the draft joint local plan
as well so in terms of the expansion of
elms well we've got three sites around
this site to come forward
we've got la 64 to bring forward
approximately 60 units we've got la 65
to enfold approximately 50 units and
we've got la 66 to enfold approximately
100 units in terms of expansion of
facilities as part of the existing
development the infrastructure
development plan which produced sit
alongside the draft joint local plan
notes that the existing primary school
is to expand to offer 420 places and
that as part of the allocations in elms
well and will fit together there is to
be provision of a new primary school in
Woolpit
to serve additional need I just want to
come from moment - the access to the
Taylor Wimpey site seen as this will be
the access to the main highway so this
is this is that access looking into the
Taylor Wimpey site this is the view from
that access looking north and then this
is the view from the north looking down
that access and we've got the level
crossing I don't know if you can just
see it in the distance there if we come
to the access plans from the Taylor
Wimpey scheme I apologize I'm not
included the key but we've got to
light-blue oblongs here each one of
those represents a large refuse vehicle
with the access road being designed to
allow them both to cross one going into
the site one going out at the same time
in terms of their master plan we have
their main link road coming here and
then coming through the site and
obviously we've got the access through
here there and then we've also got the
second access coming down through here
in this area of open space it's
worthwhile noting that there's also
pedestrian access to
at this point through into the the
industrial site the immediate South in
terms of the site itself this is a view
from south of the railway line looking
towards the table empty site on the edge
of the horizon here this is that this
edge of development they were previously
allowed and you can see that site as
well advanced the idea with this scheme
being that it would provide a sort of a
face to - to that scheme this is a view
across the railway line again from the
south because at this point I realized
that there was a stop in place on the
railway line so you can't cross onto the
other side this is the edge of the table
impede development and that's looking up
off here's the best view I was able to
get all the psychologists for this one
members it's currently grade three
agricultural land it's not currently
cropped and then this is the view from
the edge of the Taylor Wimpey site till
we get to stop and we can see the land
sort of dip down and away from the
development there now in terms of
highways we've consulted with the
Highways Authority based on the
transport assessment submitted they are
of the opinion that within the wider
road network the only Junction within
arms well that operates above capacity
is the junction from Church Road to
School Road however their content that
sufficient alternative routes within
Elms well and the surrounding area exist
such that if people leaving this site in
peak time were considered were concerned
sorry with with queuing traffic at that
junction of school Road to Church Road
they would make alternate provision with
regard to the layer of the site itself
and taking the access point from the
Taylor Wimpey site highways have no
issue although they know that the
arrangement is not ideal and they point
to this other design guide require
development of over 150 units to be
served by more than a single access in
wider terms the site is well well
spatially related to the rest of arms
well and its services and facilities
although in terms of the adopted
development plan it's outside of the
German boundary and in terms of the
emergent joint draft local plan so those
are on order but never mind you get the
idea it's also outside the boundary the
boundary obviously being this purple
line that includes the edge of the
Taylor Wimpey site but doesn't go
further off here either
everything else is as within the report
members although I draw attention to
points 3 1 4 3 19 and twelve point six
when I refer to ourselves of town that's
obviously a typo and my mistake that
shouldn't be there it's a village okay
I'll turn things back over to you chair
in case there's any questions from
committee thank you very much indeed
members question yes councillor
Humphries and then councillor gold okay
thank you I'm just a point Clark ocean
where it's at page 51 which is from
highways accessing the term allow it
talks about a single access but actually
their comment is proposed development
access is two points of vehicle access
or Taylor Wimpey development is it
single access or double access to the
site
this proposal in terms of judging this
application on its merits it has two
access points but obviously those two
access points go into another housing
estates that leads through to get to
Station Road as a single point of access
so now we play the game of the guidance
on that issue I did we did have a
discussion about that before we came in
and I've got a few note stuff but might
help members take that comment further
if you don't mind I've written these
down because I thought it'd be useful to
make sure I made sense as we go but the
so what we're dealing with effectively
in terms of this access issue is page 16
of the suffolk design guide the suffix
design guide is a very old document it
is adopted by all local authorities from
including with suffolk and it was
adopted in 2000 and it's currently held
by Suffolk County Council it has not
been updated and therefore it is not
updated as a consequence of the coming
of the NPP F which was in 2012 the first
NPP F and he is also regarded as now
today document by the Highways Authority
in fact that actually stated on their
web version and what the Highways
Authority have done since is they've
commissioned or taken further the manual
for streets and obviously their own
parking guidance so ultimately they have
more weight given to those documents and
that's not to say you can't give it
weight because he's adopted and he
hasn't been unsaved it is a saved
document currently as the current design
guide we are in the middle of
commissioning a new design guide but
that's you know work and project has
been ongoing for about two years so far
and I don't know when the in date of
that is however going back to the design
guide what it actually says is for major
access roads serving more than 150 and
up to 300 dwellings two points of access
should be provided
however it then also says we're only one
point of access is available the road
layout should form a circuit and there
should be the shortest practical
connections between those circuits now
looking at the layout what that
effectively means is there is a circuit
here you know there are alternative
routes looping as it's also called
within the existing development has been
approved and those loops will be
continued within the proposed
development put forward and but the
reason for these loops and the reason
what we're talking about here is not
actually about traffic generation in
terms of the number of houses it's in
relevance to access by file appliances
so ultimately what we're dealing with is
how do you get through an estate in
terms of an emergency and therefore a
fire appliance that leads to get through
the estate quickly and effectively to
get to the point of the fire and if one
of those routes was blocked because of
parked cars or because of the fire
itself or another reason what is the
alternative available and that is
essentially why they've fixed a hundred
and fifty dwellings as a start point
before you get into the source circuits
and so on we already have a hundred and
ninety houses of one single access here
so it's already in excess of that
guidance of one hundred and fifty we
have actually got situations in mid
Suffolk which are far higher than that
not least the allocation of children
leaves and stone market which
effectively has eight hundred and
fifteen houses served off a single
access now that access that particular
development does have an emergency
access available but it's not a second
access in respect to the guidance
criteria but it has a sit there but that
emergency access only kicks in when the
trigger point of four hundred and fifty
houses comes along because of the way
the site's been developed but you know
so what would date basically saying here
is is we need to have reassurance that
the emergency access element is
available as a different
routes through the estate and in this
case we are saying that the proposal and
you my colleague alluded to this with in
his presentation in respect of looking
at the the routing that we feel that is
satisfactory here in this respect and we
don't have an objection on the highway
side on that basis
does that help amplifies it greatly yes
thank you for that
Katz the gold you are next and then
counselor riches also on on highways
Thanks also on highways first to help
with some initials
what's RFC as on page 18 it refers to I
guess seized capacity are is Road maybe
but what is f4 in this context
that
yeah I mean it's
right in the context of the sentence
it's about the plasticity presume that's
per hour
Indiana traffic generation but I'm I'm
oh yes you have me there and I should
know that say it's the F it's vexing not
always probably Road C is probably
capacity bit anyway look erase yet right
okay okay
I'm now much wiser and I have a chronic
unease when it comes to highways
assessment this is a question it is this
has since they're about a video survey
being undertaken a view of concerns
about perception joining the mourning
period parents that children go to
school been at risk
they say video survey was taken it was
observed there were no pedestrians
taking unnecessary risk to be meaningful
that would need to be a survey at the
appropriate time sampled over a number
of occasions I wondered if there is any
confidence or anything you can say to
boost our confidence in that in that
assertion so that will have been
provided by the applicants as part of
their transport assessment and I'll live
then being assessed in and of itself by
the Highways Authority who have then
come to their view so presumably when
they were undertaking their assessment
of the transports Testament I've said
assessment too many times it has been
looked at and it is considered to be
meaningful evidence
Oh sausage so you have in effect
satisfied yourselves as to the the
validity of that assertion yeah
obviously they follow her make up an
apology in terms of what what that
standardized peak times for that survey
to take place and ultimately there's
going to be variation between the
different traffic surveys that we are
presented with but ultimately the your
your experts which other the Highways
Authority are satisfied at the evidence
that they've been presented with in this
case and we've followed through with
their recommendation I'm sorry chair
Mike yes in your question around the
Suffolk design guide requirements around
access but that's already being
comprehensive vln so to say thank you
right any further questions
councillor Mansell thank you for
allowing me to ask a question and I
would just like to comment that I think
it's a pity that there is no
representative from highways here
because in addition doesn't hang on this
is a question she's not really it is a
question it is a question about highways
and I think the highways people may need
to answer it but I could still quote the
question in addition to the comment the
question from counselor Gould I think
there are some inconsistencies in what
highways have reported there is a
suggestion that residents will choose to
take alternative routes to avoid the
school Road Church Road junction which
is already over capacity I'd like to
know what they think these suggested
routes are because I have doubts about
their suitability and efficacy they also
make a statement that pedestrians and
cyclists will benefit from improvements
at this Junction but what are the
proposals for the improvements at this
Junction there the sort of questions
I've already got down for later in our
debate but they're very valid questions
I must admit I know your area extremely
well and my questions related to it
which I asked in the briefing is how do
you get round the roundabout to go to
the wall pit pedestrian wise and cycling
and what were the alternative routes I
think it goes by Pakefield and god knows
what not
that I want to know the answer to those
alternative routes as well and you know
so I'm with you 100% on that so Daniel
do you have any response to that
nothing's been provided to me from
highways to give you further information
on that no any further questions for the
officer no thank you very much indeed we
now have the parish council chairman and
he will make his comments obviously
within the three minutes and it's
certainly a question we can ask him if
he knows of alternative routes that he
can help members on the committee for
give us an answer to that when we get to
it
thank you chair members will have seen
the comments of Elms will parish council
reflecting the views of the residents I
needn't go through them my council is a
very aware of the the policy arguments
particularly settlement boundary etc and
particularly the harm element of that
has been stressed earlier today and the
the current lack of protection from off
plan proposals such as this plucked out
of the air however as a human level I'm
asked to reiterate concerns regarding
number one the CCG assessment that
Woolpit health center can keep up with
the population explosion within its
catchment it's proven at the moment that
it can't is rather aspirational to think
that it can number two our ward members
are fighting for a reappraisal of the
primary school provision so as to avoid
the daily busing of our youngest
children over a 14 the officer confirms
that we are on our tiny little site
going to accommodate four hundred and
twenty kiddies rather than the current
number they are not enough places to
deal with the development the 44% uplift
in our population which is due within
the next five years but the comment from
Cantor Castle highways invites the most
period response from residents and
councils alike in fact it invites
ridicule as council ghoul is concerned
there is chronic unease about the way
highways are dealing with their
responsibilities regard to applications
such as this in assessing the recent
application sorry
several region applications alvarez
council has spent several thousands of
pounds in professional transport
assessment of highways capacity we have
reports they identify the Church Road
School Road junction as being over
capacity
so does this applicant and so do
highways and highways say this is not an
issue because there are alternative
routes from the proposed development and
it could be considered that many drivers
will choose these routes to avoid
queuing on school Road your chairman
will no doubt identify from her local
knowledge that they are they go up
through the back roads to Norton or they
come down through Warren lane I don't
have to add anything to that we'd like
you to accept the tenuous nature of this
key comment and on that basis alone
reject this application in terms of the
local plan the joint local plan the
emerging plans the established plans the
harm is demonstrable questions for mr.
death
No
I think you sort of answered my question
which I knew the answer to only I got
the name cake feel wrong it's Norton
isn't it going up and left and then God
knows where you end up coming back up
the exhaust pipe back down to the
roundabout to join the a14 and for
members that don't know that it's
probably a talk to us root of about five
miles isn't it and can I ask the
question to get to water laying you'd
have to come over Church Road anyway
wouldn't you you'd have to come oh yes
well you'd have to come pass the judge
yes the second act sorry the the
junction which is second most overloaded
is the junction which is New Road Church
Road junction you'd have to come over
that one by the picture of Elms well as
such to show these junctions I just
wonder I don't know if it's gonna be
insufficient I mean some of us have been
doing this long enough know the area or
I've lived in the area but I'm just you
know not everybody always knows it
no no no yes yes yeah I just wasn't sure
if that was close enough for you I think
people who know that yeah if you've got
a little Dom carry on can you identify
foreign language we've just it's very no
warren lane sort of more yeah yeah and
and perhaps I taught they started
building out those houses in that very
there so yeah anyway thank you mister
thank you
we now have the applicant or agent mr.
Armstrong's to Jeff Armstrong please
thank you
good afternoon my name is Jeff Armstrong
for moms from replanting and I've being
the agent for planning application we
have worked closely and positively with
your offices and their recommendation
reflects this excuse me it's important
to note that this planning application
has generated only one letter objecting
projection for local residents
also for your information Herald states
are the strategic arm for retro homes
this guarantees the delivery live sites
if we receive a positive resolution
today the committee report is very
detailed and covers all of the relevant
issues so I don't want to repeat these
again however there are a number of
points which I would like to highlight
the comments raised by the parish
council are all covered in the committee
report importantly the County Council
has higher authority have raised no
objection on highway grams I appreciate
the comments you've heard from the
parish council would suggest that there
were flaws with what they have said but
we have worked very closely with them
and they have scrutinized the
application at length and they have come
up with this resolution and
recommendation to you as part of this
committee following long debates and
discussion with our of how Harvey expert
there is also no objection on education
and the education contributions and they
are agreed and my client is happy to
make those make those contributions in
terms of the green space to the north
this is an expanded attenuation pond
already in use by Taylor Wimpey
next door it is not intended not needed
for uses of public open space the
safeguarded land for any future relief
Road has been included following
discussions with the parish council
again was not a requirement from the
highway Authority the final solution for
this road will be dealt with that
reserved matter stage at which time time
the neighborhood plan should be more
advanced again that the committee
reports notes that the plan has not
advanced any significant stage yet in
summary this is a highly sustainable
site in a highly sustainable location in
one of the larger settlements in the
district the application one delivered
22 new affordable homes public open
space and player
is with the contribution of a hundred
thousand pounds towards pedestrian and
public transport improvements in looking
at the overall harm your committee
report clearly states it said that there
is no resulting adverse harm to matter
such as highways landscape noise etc I
would therefore ask you to accept the
officers recommendation and grab
training permission thank you thank you
to members have any questions at all
thank you very much indeed if you'd like
to sit down thank you one point that was
raised by mr. Dow and we raised it at
briefing was with regard to the capacity
in the local doctors and schools and so
on and that we know there's more
development coming at it and so on so
just before we come to your good selves
if you could just amplify that point
please Thank You chase so in terms of
the draft joint Local Plan you always
have the infrastructure delivery plan
that sits alongside that as part of
which we'll consult closely with the NHS
Clinical Commissioning group as well as
the education Authority so they're aware
of all planned allocations are coming
forward and can make contingency for the
increase in people numbers and for
patient numbers in responding to
consultation on this application we have
a response from the NHS who are they
state that the current surgery does not
have capacity to meet the demands of the
additional residents but would take a
contribution from community
infrastructure levy in order to manage
this we also have comments from Suffolk
County Council's education authority
showing again they were looking to take
contributions from sale to manage the
expansion of facilities in the area as a
result of this application that's in
line with what's already been brought
forward in the in the IDP the
infrastructure delivery plan I just
thought that was important to note
before we
to carry on so we now come to our board
members and who would like to go first
please
councillor Mansell thank you very much
thank you now I I cannot currently
support the principle of development on
this site because of the strain it's
going to put on the infrastructure the
site sits outside both the existing
settlement boundary and the proposed
settlement boundary in the draft JLP
Elms law already has a planning
permission for six hundred and
thirty-four dwellings which are at
various stages in the planning process
and there are as another pending
application for 104 houses on school
Road the school Road site and another
site and other sites identified in the
JLP
claim that there is suitable for
development of a further 200 odd houses
so this development if it goes ahead
will put further strain on the already
exhausted infrastructure capacity of
Elms wall and the surrounding villages
mainly highways and education we have
already mentioned the Health Service
which is all pit and is currently over
capacity paragraph three point one six
on page 27 of your report states that we
now have an established practice for
sill funds to be used to enhance
infrastructure
I'd say we're only just about beginning
that and we already know that those
funds secured through CIO will always
fall far short of what is actually
needed to provide those infrastructure
enhancements now I'm going to comment
mainly on the highways issues and my
colleague Council of geek is going to go
into a bit more detail on the education
provision which is to provide a primary
school in Woolpit
now I've already intimated that I think
that the highways comments on this
application
have a few inconsistencies we've heard
from mr. perigee about the single point
of access issue Suffolk County Council
admit that this is not an ideal
situation to have 255 houses of one
single access point on to Asheville Road
this site is north of the level crossing
which admittedly highways have said it's
not an issue but it isn't you know it's
something that the the residents often
do comment on and highways have
suggested that added traffic from this
development would add a further six
seconds delay to anyone waiting at the
level crossing but I think that the
number of operations of the cross a
barrier quoted by Suffolk County Council
only takes it to cut injure trains no
Freight and slow freight trains the one
that caused the barrier to be down for
longer periods of time and we all know
that we're going to have more Freight to
a front felixstowe the main concern is
the school Road Church Road junction
which we've already heard quite a lot
about it is already over capacity they
stated in the report it's at 1.05 and it
one is capacity they start to raise
alarms when I believe it gets to about
eighty eight percent capacity and we are
over capacity and they say that the main
issues are pedestrian cyclist safety and
Driver frustration caused by delays
there is a mention of improve provision
for pedestrians and cyclists at that
junction but we've got no idea what they
are the alternative routes as has
already been mentioned by parish Clark
are not really a practical alternative
to avoiding that Junction so I think
that that is a little that comment
should be taken with a pinch of salt so
in terms of the pedestrian with cycling
issues we haven't got any plans for the
mitigation of the school Road Church
Road junction we don't know what they
are and yet we're told that we're going
to benefit from them and we must have
the improved pedestrian and cycle routes
for this and all the other developments
announced well because the as has
already been mentioned the
infrastructure delivery plan is
suggesting a new school that will pit
which so that's approximately a third of
Elms Wells primary school children will
need to go across the a14 and by some
means to get to school in war pit now
whilst we welcome some funding towards
the proposed pedestrian cycle route
between the two villages we'll put an
ounce well
a measly 50,000 pounds will not make
make it all the way and what you know
where's the rest of the money coming
from
when's it actually going to happen we if
we are going to go ahead with the
proposals in the IDP we need that cycle
it is essential there is so much
symbiosis between the two villages
health provision is in wall pet the
stations announce well there's a lot of
movement between those two villages and
if I've got time could I light also
correct the officer about the closed
public footpaths that he talked about
over the railway line it does have a
temporary closure on currently the
temporary closure I believe has been
extended it is never going to be
reopened
Network Rail are allegedly going to be
providing a new public footpath link on
the north side of the railway line from
the back of this development and the
existing Taylor Wimpey site to an
existing public footpath network at
Parnell Lane near alcohol old Hall which
is the listed building on your diagram
we've yet to know when that's going to
be happening as far as I know Taylor
Wimpey who are developing out the site
have done their bit and it's up to
Network Rail they are meant to be
closing that pedestrian crossing as part
of their improvements to pedestrian
crossings of the railway and providing
us with a another link to the public
footpaths network so as far as I'm aware
that that closed currently temporary
stopped is never going to reopen sorry
Sarah before I come to members for
questions and you raised many of the
questions I raised myself actually and
that particular footpath or the bridge
going across the river does the footpath
still run to that closure because it
used to go between some horrible fencing
and stuff the footpath on the north side
of the railway line it goes through the
estate the new estate and then it it
disappeared there is a little passageway
between some houses which is going to go
to the railway line and then there I
think on the Taylor Wimpey side
is a small section which is on their
land but where does it go to then isn't
it just goes just as a dead-end
yes because Network Rail are meant to be
providing their other end on the other
side into Hall Kent Lane it's still
there but it's just as the officer will
have gone he would have gone through
that it's just between two fences and
ends in the stopped crossing yeah yeah
can you confirm that when we discussed
the tiny wimpy site some years ago that
these these matters of the footpath
diversion and the closure of the
crossing of the railway line etc etc
were all part and parcel of the
discussion at that time but they
progress to be reporting not as far as
I'm aware or I have added I did hear
from Taylor Wimpey that they'd done
their bit as part of that condition to
deal with that railway crossing but
Network Rail haven't done their due and
getting conversations with net where
rail is as you know extremely difficult
yes
yeah there is there is one other
actually that I don't know offices are
who's who might answer it possibly
accounts the main circle they can you
confirm that if you think there are no
freight trains included in the numbers
in the report which would you like to
confirm that the network rail wish to
double up the frequency of the
Peterborough service and also that when
the work gets done at wholly Junction
the they also want to get more freight
trains through this crossing as well
yeah that as I understand it we we have
a long-term promise that that they will
be putting a hourly service switch to
Peterborough no benefit of valve ugh
they probably won't stop but it will
make very go down again and we
are going to have a lot more freight
once they finish the the loops for the
Felixstowe line from the felix though to
the Midlands just on that point do we
know when that's likely to have been
completed or is that sort of just in the
pipeline right okay thank you and any
further questions for councillor Mansell
if not we're last counselor gate if you
would now like to present your side of
the debate please thank you thank you I
also don't support the principle of
development on this site councillor
maxilla mr. Dale covered high rates in
detail obviously and I agree with their
statements but I'd like to look in more
detail at primary school provision but
papers on page 28 say that there's a
preschool and a primary school within a
12 minute walk but this is entirely
irrelevant because won't space in either
of those for children living in this
development on page 21 it's explained
that the children from this site won't
be able to be accommodated a Townsville
primary school not now and not in the
future all of this developments primary
school children will need to be
transported outside the village and the
current plan as you know for further
primary provision for Elms wealth
children is in Woolpit
page 21 says that increased primary
provision is essential and States at a
new school at will put currently in the
infrastructure delivery plan will have
the potential to provide for this
development but that primary school
doesn't yet exist and the planning
application that would provide their
land for it isn't yet determined there's
no tradition in Elms well of busing
small children to their primary school I
accept that there are in many small
villages that don't have their own
primary school but Elms well doesn't
have that tradition and there is as
we've heard no safe walking route to
Woolpit
this developments s106 contribution is
only a tiny fraction of what would be
needed to build one so of course many
parents are going to decide to drive
instead which leads to yet more
congestion at that single access point
to the development to the estate at the
level crossing which is the only level
only railway crossing for miles around
and at that junction of school Road and
Church Street and you all know the
implications of that more stressful life
more accidents increased air pollution
and of course the worsening of the
climate emergency that this council
supposed to be tackling as a matter of
urgency in addition if a substantial
chunk of our soils children ultimately
one-third are going to go to a primary
school in a different village what is
that going to do for Elms Wells
community cohesion if this is given
permission and built we have got to
provide a better option in the interests
of the whole community as the
infrastructure team say if we are
looking to support more housing
announced well the strategy for
increased primary school capacity will
need to be revisited just a couple of
other things play areas and open spaces
are also of relevance to families I've
got doubts about how both of those are
going to work in practice there are many
problems with how they've been presented
in the in the papers now you're not time
constrained please I could see you
getting redder and redder and I thought
Mary's do okay I have I'll slow down
because it's easier to hear me if I'm
slower page 32 paragraph 12 foot 4 you
might like to flick to it it's a little
beauty a bit of time for that stated
that the village has a good local bus
network I'm not sure that mr. Cameron's
in the habit of trying to actually catch
the bus of Elsa because the actual
service isn't good it's sparse it's
unpunctual worse it's unreliable and
it's getting worse it's declining so if
anybody was really relying on that it's
not it's not reliable and lastly I'd
like to say something about economic
benefits and sustainability patient 7
paragraph 3.14 we we get this paragraph
a lot and it talks about the employment
that construction will provide house
building is a powerful stimulus for
growth it both creates and supports many
jobs while it is going on
well yes it does but then so does coal
mining we can't cover our countryside
with more and more development just
because it creates jobs while it's being
built these houses are going to stand
for a century or more the carbon
emissions caused by their building will
be around for even longer we have got to
look to the future rather than
concentrating on the short term and
there I will stop as I'm sure you'll be
glad to hear
thank you I'll making into that for the
future it's a question oh yes and one
thing you said and it might not be
necessarily for yourself and I might
have misheard it and I apologize and
Daniel might be able to help us or John
you said the school wasn't being
expanded at whooping but I think it is
isn't it they haven't we passed all the
houses - then give provision for the
school and the health center can
somebody help me on that I thought the
school was expanding so as I understand
it from the infrastructure development
plan the school in Elms world will be
expanding capacity - no I'll do I'll do
policy so Elms was expanding to
accommodate 420 people places allocation
la zero nine five and we'll it makes
provision for land to be given for the
construction of a new primary school
which will deliver 500 people places but
has Suffolk County Council whoever
agreed to build this it's not a it's not
a application yet we haven't got a
clarification in the application know
that the land would form part of the
allocation so when the application comes
forward the land will be provided as
part of it right okay what I'm thinking
of then is that we expanded the Health
Center wasn't it that was the car
parking around the back and then there
was something for the primary school
around the back of that they designed it
that yeah that's okay right okay
I keep pressing the wrong button I'm not
quite sure where we are questions for
cats the gate kiss please thank you that
was Mike that was my plan yeah yeah
there's a couple of couple of things
actually that have been alluded to to
some extent or rather is the the school
transport of the children from Elms well
from from this development to Woolpit
is that is that free or paid for second
question is the has have you any idea I
suppose this is for either either ward
member the the the the actual cost of
providing the proper linkage I mean I I
looked at fifty thousand pounds and
thought mmm
yeah this is gonna cost a lot more than
that isn't it is there any idea
realistically of how much it would cost
altogether to do to do the linkage
across the EI fourteen bridge and before
you answer that can I just ask the
officers whether a cost of the school
bus is relevant in planning terms
well I'm not sure is it relevant in
planning terms it's just on being told
one thing one way John and I'm just
checking the point for you before we get
to the answer of it but anyway right I
mean I don't know whether counselor geek
knows about the processing of this or
whatever so and if you have the answer
to that to my knowledge it would depend
on if it's the nearest school of the
place and it probably would be because
that's been over the other school and
also it's cool enough so the existing
one would be full if it's over two or
three miles depending on your age which
it wouldn't be and whether or not
there's a safe walking route and as
there's no safe walking route in that
case as far as I understand it Suffolk
County Council would pay for the buses
that doesn't that's but that is purely
the economic cost the monetary cost they
wouldn't pay for all the other costs
such as congestion such as carbon such
as miserable life in will pitch yeah
let's not debate it's just a
question-and-answer situation any
further questions for counselor gate can
you just hold on a minute please
Sarah yet carry on counselor yeah focus
yeah the other one was that the the
neighborhood plans we mentioned at
various points and the the officer said
it has a little material weight I
wondered if if one of you could
elaborate how far you know how much work
has actually been done on it I think
that little weight is probably a little
bit unkind just one moment just before I
in terms of the neighborhood plan I'm
not gonna be a judge of how much work
got into it ultimately I'm sure a lot of
workers got into it in terms of its
actual weight in planning policy terms
it's as I understood it doesn't have not
one through a pre-consultation
stage therefore has is very little
almost as little as you can get weight
in the context of planning so at this
stage we really haven't given it much
answer to a question please do yes if
you would please yeah John asked a
question about the cost of a cycle route
between the two villages now I I haven't
got anything up-to-date but I do know
that about 20 years ago or just shy of
20 years ago I was informed that just
fencing and surfacing the land which had
already been purchased by such strands
down school Road Elms well would be nigh
on a million but which seemed absolutely
ludicrous to me at the time but I have
no idea what the actual cost but 50,000
seems like a drop in the ocean and in
terms of the neighborhood plan I
completely agree with with fairness to
pay with Jesus comment an awful lot of
work has gone into it but unfortunately
it carries negligible weight if I might
just pick up on the cycle link at this
moment in time your local plan there is
no neighborhood plan provision for that
linkage in policy terms and on that
basis for example there has been
development in war pit where that has
been discounted because there is no
policy basis to secure it there is also
an argument that you have to play out
which is whether it actually is there to
mitigate the burden of this development
or it's a wider benefit and betterment
that needs to be dealt with by the local
plan process
right over unto the gate there who would
like to kick off please no go on cows
I'm not sure thing I'll do wait and but
just before before I began kind of just
a clarification that this is a
brownfield land site no I think it's
appeal the presence of food so you've no
it's not it's decide the or bacon
factory it's not clusters brownfield
site correct
thank you okay that kills about 50
percent what it's gonna say so thank you
for that it's already been argued and
explained that these Civic design guide
is update and it's a guidance reference
anyway so garden stock makers word such
as may could perhaps recommend since its
guidance and it's interesting and it is
used but it is guidance
whereas policy is shelf will do okay so
policies to keep it not the guide so
policy in the MPP F and all that it's
definitely got more weight in France
substantial weight if we go back to that
guide though it's interesting that even
though it's out of date and it's only a
guide the developers and also the
planners have to take it into
consideration and even though there's
only one access road which is no is one
of the bones of camp and contention
there is a loop and the loop satisfies
the guide satisfies policy also
satisfies interest in the emergency
services because they don't comment on
it at all and it was designed with them
in mind so it sort of ticks all the
boxes really this is state and the
layout and also as president lead
certain children these is a classic
example where we've already allowed it
in other places so think the access and
the single point access is not an
arguable point personally when we go
back to policy I can't find anything and
I've read through this Simon Tom again
now
but you can reject this applicational in
policy one of the things though to give
a little bit balance to it that stands
out for me is the educational need and
lack of provision and that is pretty
critical and I think on page two the
response from Suffolk County Council and
it talks about the requirements and it
talks about that school you're on about
chair it says that local catchment areas
realms will X with preschool thirst and
Community College they have no surplus
places in any of those schools in the
catchment area the strategy at the
secondary school level is to expand
thirst in Community College
the earliest strategy at the primary
school level responding to previous
planning applications is to expand the
existing Elms world community primary
school by 105 places from the existing
315 to 420 but the important bit is
however this expansion project will not
be able to do with the pupils arising
from this proposed development and and
this is a bit that really sticks with me
that there is no provision for education
and any provision for education will
come way after this planning permission
and development doesn't sit well we
could go down the NHS route as well
where there all right they're already
talking about we need SIL to provide the
services that required for Elms well
currently and a local area and this
extended planning application so there
are definitely not enough places for
education and there are certainly not
under provisions for care there two
really important aspects and although
the policy and there's lots of things
that say we should go for this and we
should accept this and we should allow
this to be developed there's the other
side of it there's also policy I think
that we need to provide education and we
need to provide care for the communities
and we can't do that currently having
read this document in full to my belief
unless anybody could argue against that
point
and this I'm going to be corrected by
the case officer when I look at the
school provision side of this argument
one question that hasn't been asked or
answered is what is the current ratios
of catchment in respect of the scores in
question so ultimately this capacity
overall to serve the area and whether or
not that means that any children will be
effectively squashed out and have to
find a longer distance to travel to get
to the next nearest school which the
county would have to pay for but
ultimately I don't know what children
are coming into Elms well that would and
what children are going into warp it on
the basis of how this development may
change those v-8 ratios over the next
five year period I don't have that
detail I don't think we do have that
detail our assumption because the
education authorities the education
Authority is that there have major
considerations around that and looked at
the next five ten years in respective
education version in this area but
unfortunately this is whereas local
planning authority we start stepping on
the toes over the education authority to
tell them how to do their job or not so
I'm conscious about that in terms of the
NHS and the interesting relationship the
planning has with them ultimately we
have a community infrastructure regime
which gathers money to react to the need
as opposed to plan for the need and
because of that we you know when we had
the 106 provisions as one way forward
previously where we had to identify how
this development effects and therefore
contribute towards it works the other
way around that it now needs the need to
be identified to them put the money into
it so it's it's not for the it's not the
emphasis for developers to solve all
these problems they are providing the
money that we've said for them to
provide is then for the authorities to
put plug the gaps as they
forward so it is kind of reverse
thinking and I appreciate that causes
significant problems for the debate that
counselors need to have the other
problem here we put with NHS is quite an
interesting complicated one where we
actually have a local Center in warp it
I dealt with the application adjacent to
that site which was for the expansion of
the carpark so that the because any
reason that a center can expand is by
giving it a carpark elsewhere
so it can expand on the existing car
park so that effectively hopefully makes
everything a little bit more sustainable
cuz there's a local center since that
application the NHS have turned around
to us and said well if that never goes
ahead we'll go back to the original plan
which is have a super hub in Barrie so
they are their reins don't its they will
be a provision it's just whether that's
convenient
and where it is however we diverse
perhaps a little bit there we don't have
all the answers is ultimately the answer
in respect to some parts of these
infrastructure that overlying on the
duties of other authorities to provide
on the basis of the need that comes
forward did you want to come back yeah
thank you for that I understand this is
outlined isn't it yeah this is out one
anyway so yep I've got it and thank you
for your comments Castle Matheson thank
you thank you yeah as I as I read
through this application I kind of I
became a little bit uneasy about it and
I thought well yeah so you know what
would be reasons to refuse it and and so
I went back through it again and I noted
specifically that the the individual
concerns and not to happies and so forth
from different consult ease and let me
just take you through them very quickly
right it's an order they are in the in
the in the papers we firstly find
the the travel to trouble will be
bypassed the primary education yes we
took you touch on that that's on page 17
lower down on page 17 something we
haven't mentioned but that the we know
that piling is this is under Environment
Agency
we know that pilings of proposed
foundation solution for part of the site
deep foundations have potential to
impact on groundwater resources
it's another bit of a concern being
expressed there and and want some skip
the drainage and then over the page on
page 18 how highways as we began will be
discussed that the the problems of the
over capacity of the junction with
school Road and Church Road and also in
that particular context there there's
the the pedestrians and cyclists would
benefit from improvements but there's no
actual so there's a safety issue there
which NP PFS things to say about of
course their life cycle through that
junction myself a number of times and
then turning an hour down the page the
bottom of the page access an internal
layout yeah as we've heard of game
council Humphries and so on the the
single access is not ideal but allowable
it's not good but it's allowable and
then over a little bit more we come to
planning policy page 20 and they say
that the proposal is not encouraged or
supported there are page 74 more detail
on that and then to to go there is the
very large number of applications that
are already approved which is on page 20
and 21 and has been discussed and then
finally and I skip the Health Service
one because I know they'll they'll get
the money somehow or other we find on
page 23 and in water
are saying that the development would
lead to run accept a risk of flooding
downstream which again raises another
lot of concerns now I think all of those
seven things one way in another actually
address the principle of development
which is what we're talking about today
so given all of those it might take some
time to assemble them into reasons for
refusal but I'm certainly not going to
be putting their hand up in approval of
this thank you for that counselor many
other points are highlighted myself the
purpose of planning is to promote
development and find solutions so
ultimately each one of those issues
there you know most companies will start
the biggest problem would be this to
resolve that problem we'll ask for this
and they have asked for conditions
although I've asked for changes in the
development which have been taken into
account or conditioned for as part of
the recommendation before members and
but whether you think that sufficient
use your judgment to make there is
something else to think about that in a
minute does anyone else wish to speak
no-no-no smell something
and if we can just have some room so
you'll go yeah absolutely
if if we could possibly just have an
adjournment and I'll go with the legal
officer and senior planner just for
debate harmony students sprung to mind
so the meeting will just be suspended
for short time do you want the planning
you
we're ready to resume now and thank you
very much for your patience I think the
best thing is for John to explain where
we might go on this one now please thank
you John thank you we stepped outside to
discuss the conversations that have
happened so far and the evidence brought
forward by the board members looking at
the highways comments and looking at
what is before us in terms of those
comments
we feel that we would like to redraw
this application at this stage to defer
it so that we can go over those matters
again to ensure that we can provide
members with better clarity and detail
in respect of the highways position and
equally provide further details on the
improvements that this application would
result in around those highway matters
and I so I do add an apology to to this
for not making sure that that was the
case for you today and I suspect
there'll be repercussions on that point
but we have thought it would be the best
interests for the decision whatever
decision that might be to ensure that he
is robust and without challenge for us
to do that and come back to you and it
clearer details on the highway matters
so thank you for that John on that basis
I'm happy to propose that from the chair
and Thank You councillor Matheson that's
very helpful indeed so on that with
regard to what John has just told us all
those in favor of a deferral at this
point and it will come back to this
committee we are unanimous thank you
very much thank you and thank you then
are there any further knows site
inspections plans so the meeting is now
closed thank you very much